I did I thought he was
oh you should have kids look at you
bonding right over here feeling me she
been feeling
me mar met April and moved into her
house and he's like yo support my rap
[Applause]
[Music]
career
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect what's up everybody I am
Thomas dope as Yola whatever you want to
call me this is the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys Marty has no
headphones on he can't hear what's
happening okay there's a lot of people
here today and it's a little different
guys you've been asking for this for I
don't know how long we've done this
separately individually but today is
what what are we calling
the love
line so today we have Rosie and Marty's
wife April you have seen both episodes
individual episodes all together and
we're just going to fight yep we're just
going to box each other that's why me
and April on this side and there on that
side but they don't know that me and
Marty are just going to fight them they
don't know our plan
just we just got back into town
Thanksgiving is over how was it you had
a drama-free Thanksgiving we were just
going totally most part totally chill
and chill both Sid hanging out all three
sides of the family yeah it was all good
it's ridiculous you're like going to see
my mom then I'm going to see my grandma
and then I'm going to do stash and
dashes all over the city and we're going
to go do Thanksgiving and and then we
got to go to my mom's house and then her
mom's yeah so it was cool how was your
guys' One Stop Fun yeah it was all right
great one stop cool it's actually really
hard when you're like actually hosting
to time everything accordingly I kind of
overcooked a lot of stuff we actually
cooked a turkey for the first time this
year who ate
it my sisters yeah say your kids don't
even eat it turned out really bad
actually really it funny I'm like yeah
no it was easy she was cooking from like
5 hours yeah yeah that sounds about
right that's the first time you ever
cooked a turkey though right right yeah
and it turned out like [__] we had mac
and cheese we had the beans going yeah
the mac and cheese the beans going oh
GRE
beans
be just SL them out of the can we're
good here we I got one request on uh
Thanksgiving and it's the apple pie with
the vanilla bean ice cream oh she came
Oh you mean just like on top yeah like
each other she came with frozen yogurt
this year and I almost almost domestic
violence an accident I almost had to
resort to violence you got Yogurt by
accident an accident but like hold on
they're in two separate sections to the
store no they're not they in the same
frozen yogurt frozen yogurt yeah it's
all right man yeah next time do the
shopping maybe one elbow yeah AC that's
all we did that's all we did she learned
next time anytime I send him shopping
and needs to FaceTime me for [__]
everything yeah cuz she's going to have
a cataclysmic meltdown when she realizes
they don't have the one particular
random thing she's requesting yeah
that's send me into Ralph's for three of
the most obscure items you can find
please
rightand did you smell them basil fresh
basil or like this is a spice this like
no you think there always some [__]
where you think it's somewhere somewhere
else yeah I'm wandering around Ralph's
doing laps I do laps around Ralph's too
it's just annoying yeah I hate Ral it's
terrible store do you like shopping I do
I love I like up and down every aisle
when we go grocery shopping together
gone shopping in years I just went
shopping for Thanksgiving all right
that's different talking how do you get
groceries groceries
then sometimes no sometimes I actually
enjoy shopping you are the instacar yeah
if I have to yeah you leave me to my
devices on delivery peanut butter and
[__] grilled cheese and pizza and
[__] I'm in New York I specifically
stock up the house I'm like please do
not instacart cuz when he does he spends
$300 in groceries on like five things M
like what are you doing $80 of it at is
fees yes yes that's true so that's
that's cool yeah no I I have like a 12
lifestyle as far as that's concerned
yeah as far as he he eats like
the like the bum from from Dennis and
Menace yeah exactly eats beans and Liv
the bridges beans and grilled
cheese and C is Den Emmy walks around
eating PL Dilla shells now I'm like wow
Dill shells you mean tacos you mean
toras I was just wondering what's a
Dell
[__]
toras dill showell yo man you know what
I ate the other day hamburger shell you
mean
bread bread what did Cam what did Cam
what was cam so excited to call and tell
you the other day couldn't wait call
Thomas he said call and he got on he was
so excited about like a Mexican joke I
just took him to Del Taco
INX go he's like we what do you call it
when you go into a uh Del and it's not
clean a Mexican restaurant a Mexican
restaurant that's what he called it he
he was so Juiced on it he was very
excited it's fine it's fine it's great I
thought it was funny Turles and [__]
dying he was eating Churros he was
eating D and dying I thought speaking of
churros and familyfriendly stories Taco
Bell's having sex parties yeah key hold
on hold on we got to okay you got to
first I looked down and see the first
note and we talk about churros I'm not
going to bring
Taco Bell it was a great
transition I was I couldn't find what
episode we talked about this on I looked
hard help us what episode did I tell the
Taco Bell lady story that grabbed me
help drop had be season one I couldn't I
really I want to say season
one really yeah in that room I feel like
you guys were in here I could be wrong I
don't know I couldn't find it but for
the fans that don't know this story cuz
there's this headline going on we got
tagged 10,000 times in it oh gosh and I
I watched the news article on the way up
here and it was in LA oh when I did it
was in Denver yeah oh okay but still she
could travel so first of all the
headline employees suing Taco Bell over
alleged wild sex parties that go down
this [__] said she's her what they say
it she's like I go in there the manager
is running a [__] threesome with the
other one [__] workers in the store
wait stop this is at a regular Tac in
Taco Bell in an
actual not like not like a Housey party
they had a picture oh a company party
they had a picture of the location while
they were talking about it so it made me
feel like the [__] went down in the Taco
Bell it might have been in a conference
room that's awesome do they each get a
party pack of tacos though well she said
she said she brought a guac wamo dish to
pass and then she went out to mingle and
then when she realized that it was a sex
party she went to go grab her guacamole
and everybody there was workers throwing
up in the guacamole dish that she had
brought like a drunken ready ready I
don't trust this [__] I don't either
really aggressive who goes back to get
the [__] they brought and goes hey you
know what there's bathrooms yeah there
was a guy throwing up in my bow [__]
[__] you just made shitty gu Cole
turned brown for sure put too much lime
juice and it look like someone threw up
in that [__] or it was store a liar or
store and they knew M sounds a little
too impressive for me the manager that
sounds not if you know the story going
into this yeah the story going into is
different I was in a Denver at a party
in Denver and this lady is like a fan
and she starts telling me that she does
she's the marketing head of marketing
for Taco Bell and she's like I love your
channel I love your Stuff Stoners are
the reason why we made fourth meal we
watch all all the stuff and we realize
we need something at night that's
cheaper for people that are high as hell
and then she grabbed my dick she's like
let's [__] literally in the middle of a
party weird and I went and I walked off
and I went and told Rose like that the
hell and then about 40 minutes later my
homie came oh somebody just grabbed my
Di and she's like where like that's the
same she wasn't gross no she was a
really pretty lady pretty young lady
like a white lady she was super cool
shaking hands she kind of looks yeah she
kind of look like the the thumbnail you
made shaking hands guys whenever the
girl with the glasses and the thumbnail
you made it kind of look like her uhhuh
yeah so everybody tagged me a million
times because they were like is this
what you were talking like no it's not
what I was talking about it must be a
Taco Bell thing though but also like who
wants to have a sex party everybody has
diarrhea right eat some beans and who's
here for the gang bang got that chalupa
special going down right now think about
it yeah that's gross everybody's got
diarrhea just is drunk throwing up in
guacamole sounds crazy right if you
really think about it yeah I got a I got
a there's a story like that on my list
here oh no better not be about ail or
you yeah if you want to get into poop
don't I don't think Marty meant to say
like that my mind is just Marty diarrhea
guac throw that's okay go ahead all
right this was before we started working
together you two or
us all right I don't know did you said
AR I'm like
uh we went to Santa Ana to get me a new
computer this was a glorious day oh
you're gonna tell this so so brave
already [__] his pants in an app
store uh anyway we get me a new computer
out in Santa Ana at this little store
called Mojo where I got on myter
computers from now then followed by that
we make the Fatal mistake of going to a
little Mexican restaurant in a strip
mall in [__] Santa Ana Mexican it was
a Mexican restaurant it's a hit or miss
right there well usually they're the
good ones though I didn't realized I was
getting like violent like food poisoning
obviously while we were in this Mexican
restaurant from what you don't even eat
me exactly okay okay in he was like it
was like questionable it was like one of
the like you know where you walk in
you're like either it's going to be
really good or it's like [__]
sketchy and he he started it off by that
did he's like yes you were like kind of
questionable about the the I gave it a
chance cleanliness of the restaurant I
gave it a chance okay now yeah so we ate
there it was fine and what happened was
yeah okay um well then we got
home all
right made sweet marital love okay did
we did we you might not remember that
but immediately after was followed by
violent food poison food poisoning okay
this is how you test your love in a
marriage I was to ask we had there's a
lot of questions from the fans about
questions what do you what do you do how
close are you do you guys poop in front
of each other I don't think it matters
yeah I was going to say I guess yeah our
bathroom's hell far I think it's a great
thing and super healthy right so I mean
if you don't poop in front of each other
it's like no the situation I was in is
that I was violent diarrhe and puking at
the same time
oh and just all like it happened like
that I swear to God like I'm on top of
the world I just got a new
computer just has to you know we just
yeah I'm just like it was like Dumber
Moment Like that's exactly that's all I
was thinking okay this is how much I
love him and then who had to clean it on
it it was a double thing you just get
the just get the trash can cuz it was
like a
[__] horror show and she stepped up
and helped out well that's that's cool
get you one just throw up just throw up
in the in the in the trash can like it
wasn't it wasn't like like that he went
from bathroom we had three bathrooms in
that house okay he went from bathroom to
to bathroom to bathroom you [__] them
all up that's why yeah cuz he couldn't
stand to be in the one that he already
[__] up oh my God next one and he
[__] it up and then the next one it was
making me puke more it smells so bad oh
my God you know what I would have done D
up in my
shirt and held I've done that totally
done that before oh my goodness okay
okay yeah totally done that one don't
you worry I got embarrassed I just
wanted to come out with the top
embarrassing story taking the shirt off
is the worst but she stepped up you know
we had a lot of questions
about you know what couples do when
they've been together for a long time
what's the the norm you know what's the
norm cleaning up each other's poop and
vomit when you have explosive
diarrhea yeah so be careful with those
Santa Ana uh strip mall restaurants
right where's a real one Sant like which
strip mall maybe we need to drop the
location real quick if you pull by if it
just says [__] food on the front of
it it's a Mexican restaurant oh no
that's a big no when you walk in the
chairs don't match the other chairs you
leave I know I listen I'll never do it
again no he won't to this day if we walk
in somewhere if he's feeling even a
little bit off like I don't know I don't
get a good vibe we just [__] leave
like it's just not it's like a traumatic
event for him now this this leads into
April's also uh April's funniest no this
is April's funniest moment now that
we're talking about this I wanted to
bring this up I don't know if you've
ever seen this clipp not shittiest
episode we ever
had we've gone three [__] stories in a
row that's the title that we we got him
for days all right here we go we're
going to Overlay this over the screen oh
I've seen this which one
of when he was a little baby oh yeah and
he cried dropped can't
[Laughter]
reach
just hold on you've never seen raw
motion on a kid like this clip before he
was so mortified K kicked it he's like
no but seriously hand it to me in my
hand bring it down just a little bit I
think it's like scrolled up
high catch it don't catch
it oh shoot cam
what I'm sorry
Mom I'm
sorry I'm
sorry I'm so sorry cam I don't mean to
laugh I'm sorry buddy I didn't mean it
care at
all I'm sorry I'm sorry will you forgive
me forgive me you forgive me just
kidding it's just peanut butter and
chocolate what does he think about it
now he's laughing yeah know he's
laughing I've never seen like the
emotional
so
much remember when parents used to do
this all the time that was when I did it
it was during the TR you remember that
you know what I'm going to do I'm rub
[__] on my
kid well now the new one is like the
cracking the egg on the kid's head where
it's like people are like actually
saying child child abuse yeah where you
like like oh and on the kids head they
hurt the kid is unsuspected and people
are outraged about it what yeah it's is
it like throwing the cheese on a cat I
don't know chees slce you haven't seen
that one where you throw the che slice
or even on a kid they did that too that
was kind of mean I just don't like cats
s that's all I had that's all I had to
say our cat I don't like C we heard all
about her I went through the whole thing
she's an issue she's like have you see
her in the in the nighttime with her
[__] crazy eyes she's just it's like
she she'll sit at the table just like
this but like her eyes just peer over
and she has reptile eyes and it's like
you just lock eyes with her and she just
[__] staring at you that's what she
was doing to me last time she was
looking over my purse but just at me I
was like
okay thank you I was wondering when we
were going to smoke some weed April
who's weed you are are you is that
what's happening we saw you ripping
theopus P I am I got the it right here
is that what's happening I CAU it right
here here yeah I will the fans been
getting the play by this is what I'm
doing today look at these little little
Choppers you want you want to smoke
this how far are we into this cuz this
could get really
[Laughter]
aggressive let me light it too okay hold
on okay ready Story Time P Diddy's
getting in trouble for being a a graper
graper trying to be monetized here he's
a graper is not helping us get monetized
guys my bad so let's just say I just
want to say this right
now 50 cents been telling you 50 cents
been saying this and everybody just
called him
mean all right let's just say that I did
I thought he was
oh you should have kids look at your
bonding right I'm over here this man is
feeling me feeling
Marty met April and moved into her house
he did and he's like yo support my rap
career you know what I'm going move in
I'll be a com rapper y wait your dad's a
mechanic can you have him fix this oh
wait no he blew the engine [__] okay
never mind I'm actually the one that
puts everything together I build [__] do
you yeah what's the last thing you built
this family you're supposed to say this
family before we started she just said
yeah how she redid the bathroom yeah I
know I I know I was like what are we
just talking about do you know what
would have happened if that was left up
to me it'd be a be box a trrap house it
would be a box with paper on the wall
just like mine
would I can't build I'm good yeah he's
not a builder either it's a different
part of your brain it totally is
Ikea I build Furniture I can hang [__] I
can find the [__] stud I can do all
that sh I don't know about the whole
stud thing but I like putting stuff
together in theory opport Miss
opportunity I can find the
stud and good all came collapsing down
cuz I didn't find the stud but note to
sell for next time oh p d's in trouble
oh yeah back to that oh it's just yours
that's you no oh here I'll share I'll
share with you this I'll share with
you don't
worry
okay D or how about this just put it
right here when you don't want to smoke
it guys she hasn't lit a joint since
[__] Elementary School can we say
Elementary School oh my
God what's wrong with you they I'm
allergic to it I am remember when you
guys we were driving in the Sprinter van
oh that's called Hot Box
death we literally had every single
person in that van had their
giant
giant yeah but that's called Suffocation
you're normal no but it was it was
because she was sitting in
the that's
right in the middle and there was no I
swear to God no ventilation we had a
ventilation you were just sitting in the
air you were sitting in the midst of the
ventilation it was just all encompassing
and that's where the air
is I'm like hey guys just a reminder I
don't really smell P that much and and
Thomas goes oh yeah [__] so sorry and
he's like turn the fan on and turn the
fan on and where I'm sitting is in the
middle and the fan is right above my
head so this whole Cloud smoke came
right in my like literally it's like you
got like a shot got it all got it
all that's exactly what
happened okay didy gra oh gra Grappler p
is a Grappler now right he's getting
accused of
grappling that's how we're going to beat
around this we just started a new rumor
guys he's a Grappler yeah so we have a
we have all right ready now Marty's
question was did he seem like a Grappler
when you were literally by yourself no
cuz I think about that all the time I
think you see a Grappler story no her
her story I met Diddy oh no no she
didn't meet Diddy she hung out with this
fo by
herself and Cassie and his whole crew oh
I didn't know that yeah dude oh yeah me
and Cassie and Diddy were in the sauna
for like a good 20 35 minutes he's like
you make vegan food and he she broke
tell the story go okay so I used to go
to this one uh spa location all the time
for my facials my lady is amazing so I
get there and apparently it was supposed
to be shut down that day like whenever
they have certain guests or people in
there they kick you out they shut down
the salon no one's allowed to go in but
my lady was like no she's fine she can
come in and then they told me like no
phones no this no that I'm like okay
hold on hold on but it's not a salon
it's facials a bunch of rooms and it's
two stories there's a pool there's a
style sh it's like a whole place like a
resort spot Hollywood it's like a they
call it like a Russian bath house yes
like one of those that sounds sketchy
that's what I thought it's not it's very
cool it's amazing super high hostile no
super like highend dope super highend
there's a bar a restaurant a lounge yeah
like it was really sick so I used to go
there all the time I go in my lady lets
me in they tell me the rules and I'm
like okay it's fine so then I'm upstairs
getting my stuff and then you go
downstairs and that's where all the
pools are at the saunas everything like
that right and so I go down there and
I'm like damn who are all these people
not going to lie look like a freaking
rap video I was like this is crazy so
then I go in and I'm sitting down and I
saw him walk in I was like no [__]
way no [__] way it's him and I've
Diddy has been one of my favorite people
since I was a kid he's my first favorite
guy period the first tape I ever bought
by myself was uh what was it the the
Diddy and the family one that was my
favorite so then I'm sitting in the
sauna prepping myself for my facial
doing my thing and Diddy and Cassie walk
in and literally the table it's like
about this big and they're sitting right
where you and April are in a sauna yeah
okay so now with that experience it as
Monumental as that was for you do you
look at it differently now from what
you've been hearing no because I didn't
get that Vibe or I didn't get any like
weird stuff from him or Cassie like they
were both like amazing people we talked
about being vegan it was like right
before it was right before Thanksgiving
too so he was talking about hosting like
a holiday dinner and it was going to be
all vegan and we talked about food he
asked me what I like to eat more stuff
like that and we talked like I said for
like 20 35 minutes and then I ended up
going to like my actual appointment but
he was so cool he was so dope super
sweet guy so was she like she seemed
like she was chilling like oh yeah she
they were all hugged up on each other
like hanging out like a regular this
hell big ass [__] security guard oh
yeah hell security guard there's my slip
up I cussed but it's all right I'm doing
good trying my best I'm just trying my
best you've done really good yeah trying
to put emphasis on cuss words so were
you really like shocked like oh I was
like so excited I text Thomas I she text
me right away I was like no way for I
like I'm not supposed to have my phone
but oh my God but when you heard that
news it was like it just broke my
heart cuz I've heard I've heard stuff
before but it's just like here say like
I don't know for sure people say stuff
all the time still is here say till the
court of law I know until the court of
law you have to take everything I'm not
saying I'm on anybody's side but
hopefully it's wrong hopefully it's
wrong I have no idea what's going on he
already he got sued I would like to
thinkk all my idols and legends aren't
all scumbags just that's just me as a
fan cuz it does make me more sad like
the accusations with Cassie and him like
that makes me sad cuz like when I saw
them they seemed like how you guys are
how me and Thomas are like you could
tell like oh they like each other we're
good
I'm like I mean you could say that like
our Kelly with his girls you know like
you just never [__] know once you get
once you get a Chappelle skit about you
yeah solidified cuz they're writing it
going should we say this what if it's
not true it's true just write the [__]
that's how you that's how you know like
d SP goes no no I'll stand on
it the biggest artist in the world right
now the biggest R&B artist of all time
of all time hey what a piece of [__]
um also one time I was picking up Rosie
from that spot I was cross the street
different time and I was like oh damn
look at Ellen I was like oh little Ellen
oh that's cool Ellen's cool and then
Rosie just texted me I just accidentally
elbowed Justin Bieber and it was Justin
Bieber I thought it was Ellen no then
the second time I saw him he was super
cool it was him and his friend I was
there with a few of my friends he bought
everybody juice like every was chilling
it was so nice he was one of the nicest
people I've met too I felt bad cuz I
elbowed the [__] out of him in his chest
cuz she was turning around and she just
elbowed Dr people really really hard I
was paining at the counter you know the
counter's higher so I'm sitting here
writing on it and then I like turned
around and I did that and just Po and at
first I didn't look I was like oh I'm
sorry and then I looked up and like oh
my God I'm extra sorry I just justtin
Bieber the old videos of Diddy and
Justin
Bieber you know those videos of when
you're like that guy hits his dog look
how his dog is acting around him that's
how I felt with those videos Justin be
was like yeah we're hanging out man oh
my God hey what's up man he took him
shopping my mom's calling me my mom's
calling me I'll see you later that I was
like oh but there was a video where he's
like not answering my calls bro that's
what I'm talking about yeah he's like
sorry my management not have your number
man you know like uh oh man he talked
like the way people make fun of Mark
wellberg and yeah just like yeah people
make fun of the way he acts that's how
Justin Bieber was like yeah guy like a
15-year-old Justin Bieber like a normal
boy yeah he's a
normal yeah sorry weird I
was on the subject of Justin Bieber what
this guy's awesome that F plays all
those instruments Everybody Talks so
much [__] about him and he smokes
nothing but cush mountains that's a fact
Fair a
fact I like I like Justin be I like's
he's got really great tastes was it the
serum out I don't know but I'm just
throwing it out there like oh you really
smoke all all right he goes out of his
way to say that we have the same order
no no I know somebody that know some
personal [__] but yo we pick up the same
exact amount of everything I like him
that means you're smoking like us
nope what else you imagine if we met
Justin Bieber and he had a four gr joint
in his hand I would love him even I
would love him forever like bro you
really on the show how did we not
realize that no for real that fool's
awesome cuz my little sisters were
Fanatics as a kid when I first met
Thomas I would probably have to watch
the Justin Bieber movie like at least
four times four times before I left no
my little sisters my little sisters I
was only a Believer when they were
little kids they still love him but I
was like oh my God all right Justin
Bieber okay bro I'm going selling packs
I don't care about Justin Bieber and I
watch go this mother this fool is so
talented this little boy is so Talent
his parents must be
choosed could you imagine tomorrow if
the NFL was like Hey cam here's a $40
million sign all right you're you're
coming you're gonna you're coming to the
NFL it's like that basically come on man
you imagine if you're Justin Bieber's
mom like the new the new Rolls just came
out Christmas is coming just throwing it
out there like oh my God put poop on
your hands yeah exactly exactly don't
make me actually [__] on
you so that's insane that boy is so so
boy that guy is so touch that would be
though you you showing up to the house
Bieber opens the door hey
TR that's it that's
fine you remember that guy that has the
number number one the Hat with the curly
hair he's in Hell of stuff he has a hat
says number one the guy who does the
interviews and stuff no no he just has a
hat that says number one he's a bunch of
movies bunch of shows glasses curly hair
guy and he has a hat that says number
one he plays the same dude in everything
and he's he's just him that could be me
guys that could be me and a bunch of pop
singers videos just walk in the
background could you imagine like yo is
that be perfect on the future video the
duffel behind all the naked girls he
just
walk that'd be kind of hard I don't know
just a continuous walk through bunch of
different scenes of movies I mean of
let's get on to the
topic this isn't even make sense One
Time Justin Bieber got elbowed by Rosie
that's all that's all oh and that play
Sorry
and then we said the Diddy thing the
Diddy thing she hit me I'm like you
chilling with P Diddy that's crazy I'm
glad you said that cuz he sounded like
it all sounded very horrible but it's
like once one accusation comes out then
they all come out yeah can you ever
recover from that even if you didn't do
anything I mean obviously he did
something wrong God knows how much he
paid her to end that day one you know
he's got like two out me Cassie's his
wife correct yeah ex and then he she
sued him because she was like I don't be
liking you
no it was way worse than that bunch of
crazy stuff let's not get crazy into of
words that we can't even say on here his
own more than yes it was like uh bad
stuff damn who remember who Bieber said
his uh favorite comedian was that dude
oh yeah getting more in when we
mentioned your name we got the first
time we ever age restricted and been age
restricted
since when I no I can't say that on
camera take a little more in that
direction though as far as creepiness
not the whole underage thing but just
the creepy Kelly
[__] like violence you guys
go it's scary I think well we'll show
you the Articles after we're done with
this I don't know anything I just
imagine him going like this in circles I
didn't know anything until saw the whole
Cassie thing come out and then that's
when I will say this I think for women
like when people are like I don't know
why they took so long to say something
[__] like it is a real thing
probably scary the fu what do you think
might happen to you if you say something
especially like the most powerful person
come on scary you don't want puffy Hate
Me Now puffy coming after you I'm not
saying guilty so let's just put that out
there I'll chess bump somebody away from
me doing my resarch you had the chest
bump him a lot a
lot I'll rock I'll I'll thumb wrestle
the [__] out of somebody that's I'm
going start saying horrible situation
I'll thumb wrestle the [__] wor have you
is that your thing no I just made it up
I don't chest bump either my back sucks
do you see this she's like you
challenging me to a you I have a bad
back EXA oh you guys know how bad my
back is worse here we go hers is worse
your disc is way worse than mine which
is insane she doing the same
decompression that I'm doing I'm in the
whole therapy thing just hoping it will
work it'll work it will my mentality is
like it will
but actually my my chiropractor did say
sometimes it just depends where your
bulge is doesn't matter how big it could
be the littlest bulge and based on where
it is and where it's affecting could be
so painful even comparison to somebody
that's got double your
bulge makes sense sounds like a dick
joke it kind of does it's not that bad
if you got double your
bus it hurts
more taking a moment talk about one of
our sponsors and this is raw papers if
you've been following me for any period
of time you know I have been smoking
raws for a very long time they're 100%
my go-to paper I have been working with
them for a long time and super stoked to
say the official paper the official
sponsor of the dope as usual podcast so
right now go ahead and check them out on
Instagram that's rawlife247 goe check
out their website that's rawthentic.com
and rawg giving.com for ra wholesalers
go to hbi International that's how you
get everything into your shop and your
store this raw does not sell customer to
customer they are only wholesale you
like small papers you like wide papers
you like five foot papers do you like
cones do you like organic cones you like
ultra thin cones do you like ultra thin
Organics do you like the crutches that
are white the brown ones do you want
perforated do you want already rolled
and sealed raw has an option for every
single smoker out there the smoker
that's barely sipping on a joint with
your coffee in the morning or the fool
like me smoking [__] 2B joints real
quick guys I just wanted to show you
this I think it's really cool right
magnetic right here at the top it's a
baby rolling tray this is all you need
the artso pack comes with a built-in
tray tips papers everything but the weed
and for everyone out there watching the
dope as usual podcast we appreciate you
and if you're smoking along with us make
sure it's a raw what's up guys taking a
moment to talk about one of our sponsors
and this is Hamilton devices before we
continue go to Hamilton devices.com use
our code at checkout dope as usual 15%
off of everything and anything free
shipping over $75 30-day money back
guarantee this right here is called the
day pipe this is 100% herb pipe turn it
pack your pipe turn it it pack your pie
so you can just go like
this come on and it goes away Hamilton
device is here to blow your mind get you
high in new innovative ways and I will
say I have never seen this
before Oh my mom's here it's God Smoke's
God too cuz it's cylinder wow oh Mar you
don't want to smoke that one try this
wheed it's a fresh Bowl dude just go get
this right now it's Christmas season
holidays are coming up if you got some
expendable income and you got a homie go
blow their mind all right you got a
significant other and you know he or
she's going to like this go scoop it
thank you so much for blowing our damn
Minds thank you so much for supporting
the show back to the episode can we go
ahead and thank the fans for making us
[__] friends with Mario
[__] Lopez thank you
guys why did you play that was just like
a racist joke when you played that no
game he can't hear so he has no idea
what noises we should start just start
saying some crazy [__] I Clon bsby in my
head when you said
that
eyes um Mario Lopez is coming to the
show I'm excited we talked about him
last time it doesn't even sound how
random was it that his booking talked to
our booking well it was because I said
in the morning I'm like we're going to
post this Mario Lopez clip if you know
anybody at his team we're about to post
this clip it's pretty it's a ridiculous
before you posted it they were hitting
us back that is yeah they hit us back
because there was a slight moment where
I'm like [__] I hope he likes this post
oh because I called I called the girl oh
he pulled that one [__] yeah you're
like [__] yeah yo Mario Lopez man
he's he's down he's down because he
reposted it on on his Instagram wild
shirt my doctor when I walk I was just
about to say one of his uh like the
assistants at the doctor F was like Hey
Thomas I saw you Mario Lopez
story oh man yeah yeah that's cool
he DM us he commented on us yeah hit me
up looking like January Mario Mario
mother can you imagine out of the
warehouse real quick yes or no I told
Marty
this do you do you just watch say by the
Bell all the time okay so you know who
AC Slater is okay so what if during the
show Mario Lopez is sitting here and I
go I'm so sorry this is the first time
everbody I have to use the bathroom can
you give me 30 seconds and I come back
dress as AC Slater and don't go to the
bathroom I just come back with an aqua
blue button up somewhat of a Jerry curl
SL his outfit ready to go right and then
two buttons down I don't you get the
perm like Kelly Kapowski yeah or Jessie
come
back Jessie yeah I'm so excited that's
how I'm going to come
in yeah Mario Lopez can't wait what did
you and you educated the world about his
whole career that's probably what he
appreciated he's like I loved it you're
like I Love You Mario Lopez that's what
this is all about bro he's so cool I
mean who else out there is in their 50s
buffer than all of us with a schedule
like that he was shredded when he was 18
and he's more shredded now probably you
know what he has like we got to stop
cussing and get buffed because is Bullit
cussing and get buffed we have to Man
Trap Ross like what do you remember I
told after the show guys I had an
epiphany when trap Ross is like can't be
saying the FW and you know smoking
blunts on TV so how could I do it on
YouTube how can I expect to be paid I'm
like God man shut up you make so much
perfect sense not really shut up but no
you know you don't want to hear that
like you can't dunk anymore like
oh okay I'll just shoot from the
three you know like I'll just keep it
safe damn it but Steph Curry's a
champion from the three so we can still
be be chance what happened we were just
watching Steph Curry last night oh cuz
you went oh I was did you get too high
no we talking about how [__]
impressive that dude is oh he aged like
10 years in the past year became was
sitting there we were kind of just
really going over that me and Steph
Curry are the same height and I was
really yeah he's 6'2 and you know Victor
W minana was out there playing against
stop did you say a real name that's the
dude that oh Jack Skellington he looks
like this inflatable guys Right the
dude like the highest Prospect he's like
seven foot something but he's like is he
a
forward I honestly he was guarding Chris
Paul for some of the game I know it
Chris Paul's my height the dude's like
seven something Chris Paul's like 6'1 so
then we started looking at who's the
tallest player in the NBA lifetime no
lifetime y me right there was active
player and then lifetime player we got
curious cuz he's just so [__] for the
tallest active player all time is George
mirlan George he's from the
90s is he NBA Jam S6 or
something crazy I Ed it for sure then
bro might have had two points Steph
Curry is out here just non-stop dancing
around bombs from three to the basket he
had 35 points and six assists yeah at
6'2 but that's like saying how many
shots did did
uh oh my God
my mind just tank AB tankit oh wasn't
going to say him how many shots is tank
abig g hit on a bag versus Conor
McGregor in a minute it's like he's just
smaller like they're going to do the
same damage maybe but he's smaller he
can move faster Steph Curry can move
around the court and shoot from anywhere
these other guy has to like wait for the
ball to come back up when you have
somebody Hing over you that's 74 and
you're trying to shoot the ball doesn't
that not make it he was doing it so
[__] difficult the around that's why
um wild not a gra not a Grappler said my
take from my experience he wasn't a
Grappler
but I don't know let's hope not I mean I
hope not I mean I think if he wasn't he
wouldn't have shelled out a billion
dollars or whatever he just paid offl
stop for what I just made that up I mean
okay not that when you just said sheld
out before we started the show
this man said my daughter Emmy was
walking around with the casad DIA
shell no no was during the show no ailla
shell shell was it during the show I
don't think it was no I was sitting over
there no oh and I mean you
mean an empty
shell
are are just tortillas she's using a
dill shell you mean she eating a
tortilla plane man that that's like his
expertise though the the quesadillas and
he he literally says he literally says
I'm I can stack I can make how you roll
how you roll like yes I want do you want
a Dilla you want a luxury Dill you want
me to design you a Dilla design you a d
do you use the cas maker still no oh you
freehanded you know I'm boss we're we're
past
that send me a picture of your next kiss
do you made oh gladly gladly oh gladly
it's going be a kind of curious now do
you use like like I don't know how else
to say it but
like do you use like it's like a flat
pan like front yeah like or you just
like a regular pan yeah I'm talk I mean
it couldn't be more basic we're just
we're going to get you cheese you want
to get crazy jalapeno wait you're making
them just [__] cheese no I I have
basically no she gets jalapenos no this
whole time I thought you were Shing it
up like making
cheese and you don't grate the cheese
yourself it comes from a bag it's
already shredded sometimes multiple
cheeses I curate what cheeses are going
in Marty works at Chipotle essentially
but what do your friends say they say
Hees a good he makes a good Dill yeah
that's what he says he makes a good you
want a d I love it he does they're
pretty good thoughest thank you that's
the one thing I make that's the one
thing you make I know he does he has
like awesome yeah that's your thing we
had the grill going I was getting some
veggie burgers going for a minute but
the [__] Grill didn't
last cuz we leave things out in the rain
Rusty oh that's different you want one I
got one in my house you have it one you
can have it two of them I don't need it
all right deal new brand new OG was in
here busting out uh chinups the other
episode and then all genous out in the
his the whole rack the squat rack OG's
like Oh Thomas let me get this yeah he
he was like let me have this let me have
it what the [__] a whole squat rag no he
just getting my squat rag what's wrong
with you hell no it's like yo nice this
a sick car let me borrow this [__] let
me have this I'm going to go sit in his
car and tell him that next time we see
him damn damn let me have this I look
good in this car huh let me have this
that'd be sick how many times that
worked in life for him though he's
probably never
okay let me have this remind me of that
that f f hun
full thing I don't think I ever the
Curtis story
what ghetto
[__] Mary went it's a little too
ghetto the look in his face was April
are
ghetto my friend had the was doing a
music video for somebody and the dude
like he wanted to charge him $400 for
like being a feature in this music video
and he went to get the money from the
dude afterwards and the dude like I
thought you said
400 400 it's not 400 hey that's an easy
that's a mistake $400 that makes that's
an easy
mistake clarify
$400 not 400 I get it hey what what
ended up happening I don't
know it's one of my stories I just
thought that [__] was so fny there it's
a whole story I'm sure didn't okay story
done done story's over no a guy said
something once no that that was it that
was it that's cool I like it I like it I
appreciate it word play so hold on since
we can never just talk on one
subject you guys made a turkey and
burned it I forgot that was 90 that was
not may maybe four years ago we talked
about this yeah so you burned a turkey
you made macaroni and quad
Diaz why don't you make macaroni cheese
in there
that's I guarantee the second you do it
a chef's coat comes from the Nethers and
just wraps like a beauty of the beast
when he turns into a
guy at the end that's what's going to
happen to you you're going to come down
as a chef moving with the light behind
you you spinning the spatula around I'm
doing N1 moves with the [__] with the
spatula you do the SpongeBob episode
where he gets his sick
spatula does all the stuff you don't
remember that one I can see it I'm down
anything with cheese and dillas anything
with cheese and
dillas hold on do you make grilled
cheeses ever oh yeah okay I just want to
know white
man's get some sourdough going y i I got
The Cutting Board going now he's The
Cutting Board Dan using that I started
cutting it with a pizza cutter like
shit's elevating over here white man's D
I love that wait to get you a Christmas
gift so many ideas going in my head
right now you guys got me the D maker I
know I know I did but now you've leveled
up so now I got to now we got to think
now I got to step up your cadilla game
yo one day we got to get okay enough to
where other people can come on the show
like Gordon ramsy we need the beard
meets food dude that's what I've been
telling that F's awesome I told Thomas
already we should get him I H him he
just sent me back on Instagram really
yeah oh we'll come do this podcast and
then we go do a food challenge with him
like we don't have to do it but we no
not us we just like go with him we got
to have him do some crazy [__] on the
show I don't know what I was gonna come
up and I'm G have a beard no actually
Darby's gonna be here and be like Oh
doesn't Darby look just like you f wait
hold on who's Darby Dr Darby my homie Dr
Darby watch you're going to pop up a
picture we'll pop up a picture bro it
looks so much like my homie Derby it's
weird the guy did the back with video
with my cousin even asked me I don't
remember no oh okay my cousin watches
the same guy the beard meets food right
and then he said when I first started
watching him I thought it was your
friend Darby I was like damn okay yeah
no for sure has he ever made any weed
food I don't think smokes I don't think
he smokes I feel like he may have to but
at the same time I started looking into
like his diet plan and everything like
but no he's pretty on top of his [__] to
the point where I'm like damn this dude
this little dude's like he's buff but
he's eating he eats like a table's worth
of like hamburger right yeah okay sorry
on to this
next what
story
go and go your podcast oh oh oh two okay
this is your podcast not mine Rosy's POV
hi POV of the two this is a good one or
any what or any any any stories honestly
all right it says the story time I just
did the two-
faded Rosie's
POV the two- faded I think she was just
so [__] drunk it was the same
night I just did a story time I know you
did but I'm trying to think of yeah it
was just it was just my birth it was one
it was one of my birthdays I'm just
trying to think like oh when you were
throwing up and then I just don't feel
like there's like a lot to that story
other than you were [__] face too yeah I
don't when Thomas was telling his side
of the story I was like d she started
remembering no I I was thinking like I
remember that night of course it was
hell of fun uhhuh I remember we got
balloons we did the whole Yola thing we
spelled it out I don't remember that
From perspective like you got up and
violently went and [__] puked
everywhere and then you're like oh
nobody
noticed yeah I didn't know she was sh
this say by the then she was drunk I was
drunk if I'm drunk she's gone if he's
drunk I'm done cuz we've been in
situations where like I'm way drunker
than she is only once or twice twice
that's only happened in like years
couple times it only happened once when
we were at uh John and Rachel's wedding
wedding but he was still okay yeah I was
the only thing what he was doing was
like he was just throwing up I just had
to make sure like he was good right
there no but I was so drunk I couldn't
walk straight oh no our friend had to
help us my homie had to help me to the
elevator John that drunk too no no oh I
I randomly I started making everybody
drink yeah you did and no one ate dinner
at all oh my God we got so
we probably drank 30 bottles of I know
CU then we came back and the food was
gone they took our F they took our food
back cuz nobody touched it cuz I was
walking around handing shots to people
for some reason I don't know why I got
the spark of let's get drunk you were
like that almost the whole trip you were
down to drive yeah yeah but I ended up I
probably drink two bottles to my face
dude it was not good remember we were
counting him we're like damn what number
is this let's go you can't really tell
with him like if he get the only
difference is exact way the only
difference is he'll get a little Z to
100 though like I cannot tell if he's
[__] up drinking smok too much weed
like I can't tell until it's too late
did you tell that one story about how
like when you throw up on his mom on
your mom on the soccer mom oh yes yes we
told that story but what about the time
that you almost threw up on her mom yeah
that was another time just sits there
and he waits till last minute and she's
like and yeah but I can't tell until to
that point to that level no I don't I
don't get that I don't but it's only
happened twice it's not a thing we can
probably count how many times it's been
on my
end wait were you were drunker than me
yeah
every he's literally like gave me a
piggyback ride at my my friends dropped
me off in his mom's front yard oh God
and he came down was and he put me up on
his shoulder yeah fireman me and walked
me upstairs that type of [__] is a
lifestyle in Buffalo though like
blackout drunk this is just kind of like
a normal yeah I get it normal thing it's
small town [__] yeah it's like mer said
too I was about to say Merced like fi so
when we watched water boy the other day
that's what I felt like like that that
oh all those cheerleaders cheerleaders
like that was like my [__] oh yeah I
had cam I had cam watch water boy and
happy for the first time
yeah man he grew up a little he led em
too oh no what' you have her watch have
you uh I don't know if she watched Happy
Gilmore or not but defin watch water
board she watch water she probably like
Happy Gilmore they were laughing for
sure yeah they were laugh
all that
[__] the most inappropriate Parts you're
like like please don't do this at school
Cam's starting to get Cam like is
starting to get internet meme jokes for
like older people a little bit but he
doesn't know what they mean yeah that's
like Rocco we Thanksgiving dinner and he
was like what' he say he's like smash
smash or pass I'll pass oh
smash oh my God my God about that until
just this
moment was you talking about food yes we
were talking about smash it I'll smash
that food no I'll pass on that he's so
innocent but knows how to use it exactly
well he doesn't know how e any
appropriate moments but he really
doesn't quite grasp what it actually
means that is hilarious though like a
smash look at each other
like thinking of Cam doing that it's not
appropriate dudee that's funny remember
when he was talking about Ziggy rolling
over in defense of coyotes and he's like
yeah they roll over and show their belly
to so they don't show their orgasms or
say organs he was trying to say
organs how did you even know that was a
word I know but that's why cuz he knows
he's heard it before
obviously in the wrong context so we're
going through that yeah so we're going
through that your daughter she's at the
age of watch trolls right yeah she loves
did you just watch trolls I'm like I'm
not [__] spending $100 to go see that
stupid ass movie we took our nephew
yesterday and was it great I will punch
a hole in the wall before I watch that
I'm saying kids movies these days not
even just kids movies these days that
was a remakes dog [__] movie God I got
stop cousin see that how emphasis when I
get mad yeah I know movie sucked dog
[__] I had him thinking that somebody
was behind the curtain dropping popcorn
on his head for an hour and 30 minutes
during the whole entire time was e like
this to show my hands he was sitting
next to me we're in the top corner I was
like
this and popcorn hit him me goes hey I
like I don't know I think it was up
there the whole time and then we even
filled his hood with popcorn and then I
filled his hood with popcorn while he
wasn't paying attention and when he put
it on it fell he
goes I had him blocked that somebody was
doing it so he doesn't even remember the
movie he loved it he was not paying
attention to me he was like that
every once in a while he look up you did
it like my hands are full it reminded me
we had the Ariana in the back seat when
she was little and I was like eating
sunflower seeds and throwing them out
the
window I was just eating him and
throwing them out the window and she's
and you look back and she just sit in
the back just [__] covered oh my
God yeah um speaking of a child neglect
watch this one time I remember one time
I was with my aunt pepper my aunt peer
is 10 years older than me uhhuh so when
I was five 15 when I was six she was you
know 16 17 she wasn't like an old per
she was a kid still yeah and I I was
riding around with her I was like seven
or eight and all her homies were in the
car and I was a little kid in the back
seat and this fool next to me to start
sparking a Sig and I'm
like uh I put my my shirt over my face
and I'm like oh and I look at him like
[__] loser oh come on come on on and
then I'm just I'm just like this sucks
and my aunt's driving and then she
goes are you are you she's almost piece
of [__] out of her homie that's the only
time I I remember chilling with pepper
but he was like oh yeah huh he's a kid
like fool you are 17 years old you're
not old you're not old you should know
like oh yeah he's a baby too like me um
sorry I just thought of nickel act I
thought was funny that was your story
that or on I used to like to hold I was
so confused how we got Point
neglect do you lock the doors right when
you get in the car cuz they won't open
the door so my mom didn't do that when I
was a kid and my my I was what do they
call it intrusive thoughts right you
just do something like yo you just did
what you thought huh so I remember I
used to just try to hold like crack the
handle on the very edge of like before
it opens just so I can be like I didn't
do it oh but I be a kid in the back done
that a couple
freak out they're like oh I didn't mean
it I didn't mean you don't ever open the
door when like before we we have to do
the child lock thing Al I say your
parents never child locked you my mom no
she's well I don't think back in the day
they no she didn't have it thing yet
yeah but I always been child Lost the
Child the child's Avenue my kids have
even done that on accident then you
realize you have to on accident it's
never on accident I I was a child I
remember every step it was on purpose so
one time we're getting off the freeway
on to child's Avenue going toward Golden
Valley you you
turned and I
popped too hard on my mom's turn and I
[__] almost fell out of the car my
whole body went out of the car and my
mom just started yelling and I just saw
her reach back and grab my whole shirt
and pull me in the car she saved you
from rolling out of the car seat little
I was seat belted in okay but I remember
when I opened it I looked and I was like
this at the ground like still that's the
ground was going by I was like oh my God
I'm about to fall out of the car this is
this is why she says never to touch the
door knob I'm she's right learn and and
then she just like she pulled me so hard
it stretched my whole shirt of my neck
over my shoulder almost and then she
beat the [__] out of me yeah yeah that
was dumb so if you have a dumb kid you
should always lock the doors yeah kids
are so so so stupid yeah for sure I
think it's called being a good parent
like be Pro yeah but she did save me she
did she did she reached back and she
beat my ass but she still saved my ass I
was going to hit the ground but like my
body was outside of the door and I was
like this oh [__] oh my God I'm really
going to hit the ground I thought I was
dead I was a kid I was like four years
old asked my mom about that she like
that that never happen oh I'm the good
one okay yes I remember this yeah
actually it was it was in
April I remember what shirt I was yeah
everything sorry Emily I'm sorry
s yeah she knows she knows um sorry back
to what we weren't talking about
neglect all
right long I just had to think like wait
what were we even talking about do you
remember riding in the back of pickups
yes I did when I was little did you
there was no pickups what my parents had
horses they were know anybody with a
pickup track it was the Contra I'm
telling you it's like the [__] middle
of country [__] cuz all my dad's friends
had I the back pick I the back of one of
those old Woodies where you face the
opposite way that's baller but safe I'm
talking about the back of of
pickups no okay that's cool that's cool
you're in the country so obviously yeah
I did all the time yeah no I just
wondering are you ever see U my dad used
to let me ride on the side of his diesel
on the outside of the door there's that
handle you walk in like you hold it to
get in so my dad would let me hold on to
that with my arm like a garbage man like
this like garage exactly but I would
have to have my hand on the on the
window seal he'd only only when we go to
the dirt roads only when we're about to
load up so he couldn't been go more than
five five or 10 miles hour okay but I
remember I would do this
sometimes like whole one foot one arm
rebellious and yeah I was just just to
do it just like uh and my sister' be on
the other side my dad let us do this for
so long and then he explained to me what
would happen if he no cuz I tried to I
tried to like no hand it and catch it
we're going 5 mes hour I know but still
but no then he explain me explained to
me what happened if I fell off and got
crushed I like but he didn't say like oh
you'll die he goes the cops are going to
come and make me feel this big and I
what does that mean I didn't get what he
meant like they're going to make me feel
this small by yelling at me I was like
what does that
mean I just all right just hang on
that's what he was thinking about yeah
he was also 22 so you're going to make
me feel bad that's exact exactly how he
said it to me too it was wild the cops
are going to make me feel ugly inside oh
ugly he called me hold on hold on you
want to see
something want to see something your
homies like hey I called you fool what
the
hell what time did OG call me last night
2 a.m. thank you FaceTime thank you
FaceTime me at 2
a.m. you know what that
means he's drunk in his car not drinking
driving he's drunk his car's parked in
the lawn but he's sitting in it with
sitting in it with Mindy smoking joints
when they have a house talking about how
much he drank why I
know every weekend he calls me and lets
me know the the summary of what happened
and then I eat some
fries am I wrong yeah man I weit fries
what is I like that that poin I
like like P canadi you say it every
weekend I'm sorry you mispronounce it
every weekend oh like we correct you for
like the past six months every weekend
poutin cuz when you say when you ask for
it the only reason I correct him cuz
when he asks for it other places are
going to go I don't know what this guy's
saying he scares [__] at me I don't know
want to correct him I say it just say it
right man poin I like when he describes
it yeah but what the hell is it talking
about sorry oh you said make me feel
ugly inside my bad my bad all we do have
notes what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our brand new sponsors
and this is borash and like I said last
time I'm super stoked about these
products because board hash is actually
the facility that they get manufactured
my home runs that spot one of my close
friends and he's been telling me about
this brand for months and then I finally
saw him and tried him and now they're a
sponsor this one right here is GMO and
inside this box it explains fully what
live resin is so when you get these at
the store you can actually see every
single thing about it so these right
here are their pods these are the little
pods right here the pens so if you're on
Instagram go ahead and follow [__]
let them know the dope as usual podcast
sent you they have Edibles and these are
board hash Edibles so in these there's
grape strawberry orange lemon and blue
raspberry 100 Mig for the entire bag 10
Mig a piece so thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
thank you to board
hash it tastes [__] awesome moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is my bookie whether it's UFC baseball
football or basketball make sure you're
betting with my bookie do us a favor
right now click the link in the
description no matter what platform
you're watching the link in the
description follow that bet $50 and
you're going to get $200 instantly
credit to your account bet 50 get 200
back even if you lose that 50 you at
least you got the $200 credit listen to
what I'm saying guys it's a win-win
win-win situation also UFC 294 October
21st is coming up go ahead and bet right
there Marty and I we're going to go
spend some money even if it's just fun
to watch the fights and hope you win you
forget you could possibly win a bunch of
money too that's one thing we didn't
consider I know it's betting but it's
like it's more more fun than anything
slot games live casino table games
there's much more than just betting on
sports but remember if you're going to
bet anything anywhere anytime make sure
it's with my bookie once again click the
link in the description bet 50 bucks
that first deposit 50 bucks you
automatically get $200 credit to your
account once again shout out to my
bookie thank you for watching already
bet on my bookie and we actually won how
much money
$137 first time ever betting on my
bookie good job so this was in full
transparency this was this wasn't actual
money that we won this was credits that
we got through our sponsorship to really
understand what we're doing and to start
making bets and no one how to really use
my bookie so that we can actually really
use it and get good at it and we won
first time out we're up about
500 also I say we never talk about the
bills again and just let them win every
time we're excited
for the past three seasons they're like
yo they might be the best team in the
NFL and then week eight Mari goes I
don't want to talk about it I talk about
it we don't bring it up [__] them that's
like that's the whole fan base yeah the
life of a Bill's fan it's like I always
say it's like being in a relationship
with a crackhead that you like never
keep going back to I like the crackhead
get it's like that like they keep
letting you down or you know what's
going to happen love cuz you're loyal
God I mean I'm a Raiders fan I totally
get great like this dysfunctional
relationship one day they're going to
change sometimes they're good yeah the
past couple years they've been doing it
feels great and you buy all the [__]
when they're really good you're like
repping and then they five times in a
row and you're like it hurts to wear I
don't know if I want any more billshit
but it's not even the losses cuz we
don't just you know it's like the highs
and lows beat ourselves is what really
hurts me cuz we'll go out there against
some dog [__] we just won last weekend
we're like that's right we're so extra
with it we got this we're so extra with
it like you guys don't understand what
we're going through good
job I see oh how about all them fights
though at the Raiders game that they've
been saying what all the videos of all
the fights at football games have been
majority at Raiders or ners you can't
even tailgate at the Niners Stadium for
the past for the last three years of the
stadi cuz people get getting stabbed
that's crazy but yo yo yo you can't even
Park here yeah I just saw the
documentary on it the Andrew Kellan one
or whatever uh he just went and did the
full all documentary about San Francisco
my God keywords
triggering yeah it's Grim the uh yeah
it's Grim there was a car carjacking
went down while he was interviewing some
attic or some [__] oh my God we're out
there just like there's about there's a
whole thing of videos of people just
kind of like shaming and pressing the
homeless people for being so out in the
open with with kids walking by and [__]
it's a whole thing on YouTube oh I mean
they got nowhere to go oh how are they
going to be out in the hey cover it up
what I don't live anywhere what's wrong
with you there's a reason that it's such
a problem though like and that's the
thing like we're not getting to the root
of the problem I think the city's like
yo turn a blind
eye we're going to buy up the property
when the values go down then we're going
to gentrify it that movie we watched
last night that's what it was that's
what I think happening tyone that's what
it's about a what the Clone time with
the Jamie Fox thing as soon as everybody
said that he was getting cloned the
conspiracy like he looks different he
has a new movie about being clone how
odd what the oh I don't even know
anything about that it's like a cold
conspiracy thing I see on Tik Tok all
the time like damn people are wild yeah
guys they like killed him off and he was
cloned or something crazy I don't know
Jamie Fox is clone come hang
out how did we get on that topic though
I know it was like something totally
different April you're not even high I'm
so high she is lit it she lit that
wouldn't but like literally I took like
three puffs of that and I'm like guys
I'm so [__] up she got two little
tastes of the raw paper celsus little
tastes like I got celsius if you want
he's still trying every time we go to
the mall or anything he's like here
taste this it's the new it's a sponsor
you have to taste this me every time
like I I'm going to support but it has
the same effect every time it just gets
so high so like so
dumb I sent you the video I have all of
them I saved them all yeah it'll be she
I get her unexpected I'll just be like
Make This Blink rip this and just shove
it in her face that's what was funny
Make This
Blink de puked for 30
seconds I only saw one of the videos I
didn't know there was more oh there's
it's every time guys this is 15 years
long one day it's going to work I'm
going to CRA through one of these times
yo what if you just started smoking weed
and your back just got got better I
would love that so much nothing more
than I think it would help you not be so
hurt all the time everybody says you
know how bad my [__] is I well but it's
still bad though even with that but what
about edibl oh no I'm talking about for
pain that's all I'm talking about right
but you're still in pain you smoke weed
every day you're still in pain if I
didn't smoke weed I would be dead
honestly it was so bad at for pain I
hyper focus on the pain oh no I would
take like a tincture and go to sleep
like a little dropp got some droppers I
tried that we've never tried the
droppers this is some new school sh yeah
just teachers yeah I'll try whatever
that's it's not for getting high really
I would love that so nothing more than
that but it just doesn't under your
tongue too hits hits like you faster too
or in the eye it's just like a and when
you put your no when you put your
contacts in when you switch them out
eventually you use that you use that
okay
okay use that as
solution shot
fired that was before the show I forgot
about that damn you using ammo against
April no cuz you're like month there's
months she do you have to do it every
day guys I sleep in my contact I don't
get the weekly or the monthly she get
she every I should everybody let's judge
her for this judge judge judge no she
does every day I've never seen anybody
else how do you do that they're called
dailies I can't do them dieses da are if
I don't take my contacts out by the end
of the night they're suction cup to my
eye and dry like the idea of sleeping in
them is insane let alone for like months
me I never I literally never take my
contacts out I haven't years and years
sleeping them and if they get dry just
like do the eye drops so insane and I
Chach them every I mean that's what they
say
but my eyes are fine what if it's
causing your back pain maybe that's it
that's my Rory my back pain no your
brain can't see your back pain shut I
was
kidding no it's only bad cuz like if you
get dust particles then you just
scratching your there's nothing to go CU
it can leave scratches that's what they
say but my are good we need to break
down and get I just need Las I it's such
a hassle my mom did not do it yet no
you're Aunt Letta it I want it so bad
like the idea of getting my eyeball
peeled back by a laser seems okay I yeah
let's do it we got to do the other one
you even have bad eyes no I'll do the
surgery for you vision is
amazing I'll do what lasic will film
Marty's procedure all three of us will
do it on the show my eyes good oh your
eyes are fine Thomas Thomas has perfect
Vis I can see the front of your house
from here wow that's how good my that's
crazy which leads me to a point hold on
before I
forget is it disgusting to put up
Christmas lights on or on the day after
Thanksgiving on the day of Thanksgiving
is fine thank you and that's how it is
you're just not cheerful like me I don't
give a sh I mean your whole family is
there on Thanksgiving why
not after it's over now like come on
these are the only two times that people
try to pretend to be nice to each other
so I think people were like yeah I love
this time of year that's why we extend
it okay once Thanksgiving hits it's just
no what the real problem was is that we
had this big ass Thanksgiving dinner and
I ate and laid down I'm sitting there
watching football this is the one time
of the year I sit on the couch and she
wanted a goddamn switch into a whole
separate holiday I didn't know we were
going
there and start getting me to bring down
the Christmas tree and start putting on
all these goddamn Christmas lights I'm
TR to tell her this is the one day of
year that I do this I'm not switching in
my defense only like 3 days in advance
like that's my I like to put the
Christmas tree up right after
Thanksgiving like this BR I've been
cooking for 5 hours
straight need you to sit down and relax
got a second win a second win that's my
ADHD I'm like let's put up the [__]
Christmas tree let's do this throw your
back hurts you to take it easy look for
real you have to take it easy like y I'm
sit down stand for 5 hours
often I know but I they are I just like
to get done he was like he was I build
I'm a builder Hunter Hunter Mar's an
editor it's
[__] I just ate not doing anything
you don't want a dill you want a
dill so what were we talking about as
soon as your so hold on real
quick when your kids are out of the
house right now say it's fast forward
and Emmy is 18 years old and you guys
are done what is is the first thing you
do do you move do you go get a Sky Rise
somewhere do you move to New York do you
move to Florida do you go travel what
are you guys going to do no I think we
just enjoy some peace and quiet for
about five years we
just for a second when you didn't
say we doing
that cuz I'm already there like I have
baby fever I'm like oh should we have
one more
God insane I'm like for the first time
in our life we don't have a baby right
now I know also like that's where I'm
stuck is like I could have this whole
separate life of like having
self-sufficient kids and like now it's
just us to being sad it's it's sad when
you realize you're not going to have
more kids especially for like when the
last gr up your stomach apart though
like just did the surgery C the idea her
I'll do it again oh my goodness she
barely able to walk as is also true yeah
all my health El probably not a good
idea back not a good idea everything is
proba way back yeah all these to
PE but anyway I think I would want to
travel I would want to like go do like
Marty went he doesn't really that smile
means after the smile means we'll talk
about this later but also I'm not going
I'm falling Rich out of control I just
said 15 a private jet I feel like
something's more sketchy yes you'll be
bed by that time yeah I mean then yeah
cool like whatever yeah you still have
to chill at home for five years that's
what he's saying I just want some piece
of quiet is what I'm getting at that was
the to be on a boat he wants to see
every continent no he doesn't want to be
on in the ocean he won't go on a cruise
we talked about it yesterday he's like
no I'm change honestly I get it it's not
that I won't go on the ocean either in
the middle of nowhere I'm not scared I'm
not like super down okay I feel like I'm
like really far away this whole time no
you're good I'm not down to go super far
out in the ocean just for nothing it's
pronounced ocean yeah sorry youve been
saying ocean wrong for a it's
ocean
okay is he serious is he
serious it's but a Cru sounds like a
goddamn nightmare to me we're going to
be trapped in a room with strangers
think it would be really cool for day
two and then after that being in the
middle of nowhere in the ocean would
like I would never want to do but they
they reel me in with the experience the
all the water slides all the like shows
I'll show you some water there's water
slides I can take you there shows down
the look so fun I get it get where he's
coming from I don't after one or two
days where I'm like damn we're in the
middle of nowhere in the ocean it's in
the ocean you know what could happen a
monster could decide you know what 2023
is a year I wanted to wake up and I I
sleep in the ocean I'm back now and I'm
that thing right there I'm going to get
it come out of the water and then that's
how Power Rangers to starts right yeah
it's it's Ivan O's
son he's mixed with water and his power
is water I mean the same Could Happen
though like for King Kong like he's in I
will shoot a monkey so fast talking
about I'm talking about monsters you
know how she is though like we went to
this Lake if it's your time it's your
time I went in the water Listen to I
went in the water I think I think I
think you should be should be cautious
to a certain extent but not like to the
point where it impacts your life and
your experiences no she she's the one
standing on the bat going swim [__] you
can swim swim you got to life trck it
on wait is this a real example while I'm
oh it was real it was real okay sounds
like an example we rented a boat he had
a whole he had a whole life jacket on
yeah the buckles and everything mind you
he's never said hey I can't swim I can't
like never experience right so he went
in to this Lake off the boat with the
light jacket out of Shame wait did you
have a life and as soon as he got in the
water he acted like he was drowning what
if he was drowning were you
drowning number one that L that life
vest isn't just keeping me up all right
you still got to struggle to live with
the life vest on but you know how to
swim so it's the same I haven't been in
a lake in 30 years and I got you above
me looking at me you know like but not
in the water I GRE up and swimming in a
lake i i i Marty really is from the hood
huh you really are a hood ass fool man I
know how to swim oh Flynn I thought been
in a pool wait why would you have a pool
I didn't swim since I was 12 years old
prior to this but I didn't know that so
I didn't know that going into it
California is so much different well I
didn't realize I couldn't swim anymore
either and lakes are deep I was just say
you didn't have a homie who had a pool
no it's Hood it's just it's just it's
just where you're at cuz hoods over here
know how to swim all my friends can swim
all of them but we also have a public
pool that you can go learn right in the
G right across street from my Grandma's
was the public pool I learned it's right
across the street from my Grandma's
house a lake hits different though a
lake fish and death in there exactly
scary and you know it one I grew up
swimming in leges
we're for we're forgetting about the
part where I went away from the boat and
was swimming fine that all went down too
so when he went in with a life jacket it
was all like he was drowning I was so
confused I'm like what the f comes up on
you get in yeah actually that didn't
happen moment yeah it's a moment of like
oh no I can't swim of oh no I can't swim
Jesus oh my
God sorry I'm just imagining
the life jacket literally went up over
his face like this or like when we went
to he was dropping so just your arms
right when we went to K River or was it
the time when we went to K River and I
told you people like the white rapids
were going and the dude died while we
were out there told you about that
season one we went out there with a
group with like a church group of her
friends I don't remember that did the
guy die while you were there y group in
her group she went with Ariana the dude
fell out fell off your raft and died our
raft it was the raft right before us he
was in our group in our group that we
went with
campsite and uh anyway so go anyway man
die there's a couple people that [__]
died this weekend again right yeah cuz
it was like the worst rain that they had
ever had it was like flooding this
is California it's like K County by
Bakersfield K River so it's like yeah
and we went camping and all these people
ended up drowning and you brought him
out you went camping I know back yeah
when we first moved here oh you were
just trying to be a California guy at
that point you know what I camp now I
moved I'm Different that's exactly what
happened like camping where I'm from is
homeless so yeah go camping little don't
Camp urban camping urban camping that's
my channel Thomas urban camping it's
just me sleeping like this with a knife
oh my God move anyway this is where I
was getting at this cuz this same
weekend now there's a little natural
waterfall somewhere in the woods here
that all it's a natural water slide so
the way it's been carved out it's like
people use it as a water slide the water
raing but it's not and there is a
reality where you kind of like keep
going yeah like you got to stop you got
to stop yourself at the first little
area where the water stops cuz then it
keeps going in into the river basically
no no our kids did that yeah it was a
way it was a ways down okay it set it
over when he did it when you guys went
somebody fell off the raft in front of
you and died yes but how cuz they F had
ATT he had a heart attack and he drown
he had a heart I don't know if it was
like hard you know like but he was in a
ra with a bunch of people because the
the water was so bad and like so
aggressive during that time they
shouldn't have let people go down itan
kept letting whole year it was like in
the news that they shouldn't they should
have shut it down so
anyway I go and I slide down this
waterfall she shames me into it just
like the lake oh I'm a shamer and uh
she's going to be right behind me after
I do it she a sham you another kid so I
slide down this goddamn thing I go
underwater the whole [__] life flashes
before my eyes and now this one doesn't
want to do it after you see him almost
die that's [__] up no d no it's cuz I
don't like to be cold I didn't want do
it stop you see Mar almost dying oh yeah
want to see yeah that's right I'm
cold you're using your no way our kids
did it though that's the thing he's
feeling to no they didn't remember ar
Ariana did it no she she stood next to
you cuz I was roasting both of you
after that was roasted both of you my
daughter my little baby daughter roasted
ner look at those whack ass shoes that I
bought you whack ass shoes what are
those
I those whack ass shoes I
bought your mom got that's already does
when I have kids you act like little
bastards and you don't want to listen to
me I'm going to buy you the weakest
shoes ever you got to wear them
preemptively they're on deck the
time I'm going to make you wear Birkin
stocks you're going to do that don't
give a [__] about shoes make you wear
birken stocks with high socks don't what
if any outfit
it then we just created a monster don't
do that I take all back you're right I
don't want that don't never mind not
buying kids sock cam wears tall socks
every he's an athlete when an athlete
wears anything it's cuz he's an athlete
think about it right now why do you wear
those ass shirts fool you're hella lame
look at that athlete with a tight ass
shirt he's an athlete think about tank
top wife be oh he's an athlete though
he's bu true article of clothing by it's
cuz he's an athlete yeah slides with
socks you're not a pedophile you're an
athlete like when did tights for tights
with shorts became just a super normal
thing when people when Cam Newton
decided to just keep running with them
on and go I'm in yo stop I saw cam you
know Cam Newton has a
podcast he had that Christian chrisan
what's her name blue face chishan the
girl that fights Mike Tyson she she's
like my Tyson a chick sweet she know I'm
saying she boxes know seems very sweet K
oh yeah she just has a bad rat why is
Cam Newton talking about sexual [__]
with this woman wasn't he just in the
NFL he's talking about
graphic no way I didn't hear that she
was on his show today
oh I need to go see sorry just hearing
her talk to him about like some ratchet
ass [__]
like this is Cam Newton he's the only
person I've ever used on Madden because
he's that good and he's over here
talking to blueface's exgirlfriend does
he like that or is he like no I'm just
saying like he he looks like the average
guy from 19 he looked like any dude from
World War
III any like clean cut black dude that
went to war oh goodness that's he looks
like anybody from the ' 50s like any
really like pretty buff guy is that
smile his teeth he's got like the
generic Walmart the Timeless like yeah
the Timeless like he could be on the
side of like a an ad it's like Mario
Lopez has it thank you yeah the cam
newon just has that he looks like
anytime yeah then he's over here talking
mad graphic I didn't expect that from
his podcast man uhhuh he just started
that podcast ohy we're going here we're
going BET uncut okay Cam Newton damn uh
that the [__] he was saying was wild
speaking of graphic and uh vulgar can
you tell us about your experience with
your
counselor what me
yeah Marty's just like calling you out I
need a break for
a experience with your
counselor interesting okay like a high
school coun
okay so anyway did his last name start
with the
Leah no no okay so I say well here's the
thing wait hold on guys I feel like I'm
[__]
up this bottle of wine is gone I drank
all the wine hold
on set this up yeah she set it up she
cut that out okay and
oh I'll be
sure she had a counselor that she was
talking to like a remote online
counselor all right and had done a bunch
of sessions with her just working on
personal stuff how old were you when you
did this like recent last year no yeah
two years ago I thought you meant like a
counselor when you were a kid also
nothing wrong with counselor like a
butter like a butter situation like got
okay better help she was the counselor
in US right Jer great great commercial
great
ad so she's had uh she's been like
talking to this woman for a long time
and kind of out of
nowhere the counselor calls her one
night right or so we like it was like
during Co and everything I was like oh
wow this girl's so cool like we were
kind of started sharing like she wasn't
ever with her personal life but like
like wow we could be like friends on the
outside of this if you weren't my
counselor right so she ended up like
calling am I good oh wow so much better
so much better right yeah wow you can
list it up you have to B wow
wow so she ends up like calling me and
I'm like oh wow okay so I'm friends with
my counselor now but then she starts
like unloading on me like her own life
personal life that I had no was
unprepared for her this wasn't better
way no not even close so this this lady
is like basically telling me how her
marriage is falling apart because she's
always been like a polygamist oh and you
know like they always had like her
husband had a girlfriend and they she
had a boyfriend and all this stuff and
whatever and then it didn't work out and
then the husband and they have kids and
then the husband left her for the
girlfriend and then she ended up with
the boyfriend that they all three had
together
and it was just wild as [__] I'm like
I'm out there like inadvertently
drinking a glass of wine and I just
start like I drank too much wine by the
end of it I was out by the pool
Listening to We didn't even have the
she's sitting in the backyard listening
to this [__] I'm
asleep no and then you came out no you
came out and I literally looked at you
and I'm like
bab they [__] people
like they're like they group bang
polygamist like my therap you knew I was
on the phone with my therapist at the
time it was just like so unexpected
she's unloading on me and I'm like oh
okay because the Dude wanted to be with
the dude right yes and her current
husband of like 12 years that they have
two other kids with from a different
marriage cuz she left the husband for
the
boyfriend she got pregnant by the dude
by the boyfriend
right sorry I'm getting ah no you no
that's a that's a different
thing is this onbo different coun no I'm
I'm it was like the weirdest situation
of my life and I I don't judge anybody
like to each his own but that [__] was
just like how much did you charge
therapist and she's sharing all of this
with me did you get on your she dumping
it on you what a
[__] we were friends what a [__]
honestly I should have [__] reported
have you ever met her in person no she
was in it was like yes it was like a
virtual she was telling you this face to
face on no she called my cell phone okay
okay okay and then eventually facetimed
me this is how crazy it gets she
facetimed me and her husband that she's
considering divorcing because he loves
the boyfriend more than her now oh my
Lord God wait so they both facetimed you
no just her just her and then he came
home all drunk and like face it and
he popped in the hot tub like he was
undressing it was like a whole thing
this is my therapist
y'all and I'm like before this okay cuz
afterward you can't you can't be like
yeah
I I had to literally be like this is not
appropriate at all like I should [__]
report you but obviously you can't do
therapist anymore did you ever talk to
her again one
time one time I had one session after
that and she acted like nothing happened
it turns out she's not a therapist she
thought she was talking to a therapist
because she saw your better help I was
like this is the same lady the better
this is got to be I knew I could talk to
her H Conn I get that sometimes I have
clients that hop in my car that I show
houses to and they unload their whole
[__] life story on me
like really and I great for that Ty I
love it honestly that people feel
comfortable I to people track that it
was it was the most like inappropriate
thing this broad could have done though
literally as my therapist the way we
said it I feel like we're not even doing
it address this it's really funny kind
of like cuz how can it not be funny
because it was so inappropriate and so
weird yeah but also I don't want to get
somebody in trouble and let them like
lose their job or I didn't like report
it but we had a good laugh
like real quick I want to do this real
fast before my phone is
dead
ready no
no is there a nickname that Marty has
that he
hates tell them what my nickname is
party Mar
no no party Marty sounds
sick I say it all the time actually cuz
he's complete opposite I'm like yeah my
husband party Marty over here it's like
an ironic thing yeah it's an IR so no no
party Marty
no all right that's cool what do you
okay so I no I had a no no nickname at
all no none none and then you know
what's funny on the drive here I was
thinking like
I don't I've never had a
nickname or anything like that no and
then I thought about
it yeah
what because if you think about it like
oh depending what you call me is where I
know I know you from mhm oh no you do
have I mean if you call me wow I'm like
y who do you know in my family cuz
that's what my name name was white boy
until I was like seven wo wo means white
boy wo means white boy so that cuz I was
this color till I was like s or eight
like I was very white like I looked like
a white little boy you did and then uh I
just I caught I caught a tan One Summer
playing football I swear I swear and I
just cuz my sister my sister's D and I
never I was just always so white and
then one day I just
went very weird huh sick sick I did that
too but I just turned to
freckles same they turned to freckles no
and then I was thinking on the way
here if you know me as Yodi like also
you know
OG or Toyota wa start as I don't have
any nicknames exactly that's what I
saying then I thought about it today I'm
like I don't have a nicknames actually I
17 I have none it's just people call me
stupid [__] from different from
different times and different parts of
my it's just I could think of little
part I don't know I was just thinking
about it brosie doesn't have a nickname
and I was thinking my sister's called me
AP AP AP AP punch that but don't call me
AP AP makes you sound like a
monster right my sister
AP where do you keep her
exactly why do they keep
her oh God all right
question what is your
perspective on the time on on how we got
together and I was going to ask April
the same thing I would say I was trying
to think of what's one thing I can ask
both that we've talked about on this end
okay cuz we talk my how you me oh we
talked about that yeah she met me she's
like who's this Rich dude he's so
[__] cool yeah that's exactly what
happened I remember this what he says
have you not watched the
show no you not watch the show he
flashed you 40K and he was like that's
how I got April yeah and then he said he
said that somebody yeah that one right
those pictures went in the vault in
Vault true the watch he said April just
got stabbed I thought that was really
cool that's what he told me cuz I knew
she was down yeah he did I hired her for
security and
[Laughter]
stuff I need her to get through the
doors all right blonde she'll get us
right in and stab somebody your
perspective meet hang out get together
because ours is different
this one was like yo I'm going to move
in yeah ours was a lot longer well wait
wen't you guys younger though how old
are I think the same age as you
guys2 oh wow okay I thought you guys
like dated in high school no I knew of
him in high school okay that was it I
just knew him and his friends were the
guys who had like good weed go your
perspective oh God what meeting versus
what no meeting already on MySpace
riding around in his dad's station wagon
nope nope yeah no I had the Mazda oh you
had the Mazda I crashed that thing about
two weeks in
Muffler what a muffler no I had the high
performance muffler so was this loud in
the
muffler oh that's why it was loud cuz
there's holes yeah it was both with the
system he had like you I had holes in
the high performance muffler at one
point which was embarrassing I got it
off and it was just regular but I did
have the six
system I had like two 12s continue I had
two
12 all right so he had the sick Myspace
top eight my was cracking my MySpace was
cracking guys it was
like if it would have stuck around I'd
have been big on MySpace [__] no
literally I saw his profile picture and
he was like at the gunit studios with
his yeah gunit t-shirt in the profile
picture and then I just started looking
at his page cuz I was curious he's from
Buffalo and then I realized that he knew
goofy the same people that I knew from
where I was from and then it just
sparked a conversation from there and
then we didn't it was until like two
dates in where I realized this dude went
to the same [__] high school as me oh
really yes I know that before her before
I moved there the same year that he
moved away and this is like an hour
distance
and then ended up we knew a lot of the
same people too my best
friend from that town when I moved there
was his best friend before he moved oh
what like I I wouldn't say we were best
friends but like I was definitely
friends with this girl she was the first
when I I went to the school from sixth
grade to nth grade her last name started
with P She was the first person I met in
Home Room the first day of sixth grade
in Middle School my new school so like
we were friends you know and she's cool
as [__] throughout the years or whatever
and then yeah happened to be her best
friend and when I when I moved to this
random town that he moved away from my
first best friend was one of his really
good friends and we didn't even know
that we went to the same school until
couple dates in huh it's like
f April O'Neal like the Ninja Turtles
Martin Lawrence yeah Martin Lawrence
right O'Neal O'Neal celebrities o two
celebrities first dat Kane Street laana
dead end Kane Street dead end what's
your dead end dead end in Mercedes where
you die yeah it's scary over there you
don't date with me oh it was a dead end
it was on Cane Street I'm just saying
that was in a house we watched some
[__] movie not it was my homeboy
girls apartment yeah man you said like
you went out to bban street dead end oh
you watched a movie called dead end it
was Final Destination it was a movie we
watched why did you say dead end cuz
that's what I thought of when I was
talking about the house there's this if
you know the street on street view
there's only you said you can't live
your life like Final Destination and
enjoy it and your first date was
watching destination isn't that ironic
yeah actually I live my life by that I
don't stand by train tracks cuz I shot
Sean Williams got head that cuz I've
seen crazy [__] [__] I know so I
don't oh that's why I'm so cautious
thought I thought you would be hyp
precautious I'm like this I lock all my
windows all my windows at night I check
everything all my windows my doors
everything like I'm crazy about it cuz I
don't trust people like you just don't
know every time I go into a hotel and I
and and because I don't have camera no I
search every single body size cabinet
under everything I move everything I
check every single thing every time I
leave and come back it sucks I check
under the bed every time it sucks dude I
do the same you never might be a twer in
there I TR I trust everybody to a
certain point I don't I try to but I I
know like realistically you can't like
you just can't and you have to be hyper
I don't want to teach my children to
like be just like scared of the world
and scared of everybody but literally
trust your [__] instincts I tell my
old brother and sisters like fools will
steal you y just remember that Johnny
when he ran in front of us to the
theater oh my God I know he opened the
door like look look how big that fool is
he could have took you stay with me
oh running out like that in the middle
of the night what's wrong with you yeah
and then I just try to show him like if
you get stolen I'll never know where
you're at and what's going to happen you
have to give kids that realistic fear
just like that like it could happen in
two seconds never walk away from me and
he worked instantly oh yeah like you get
stolen and we're now we got one kid
that's like about to start driving and
like wanting to drive with all their
friends that drive and then we got cam
who's going out samot wanting to be all
in the neighborhood thehood and we have
to be like you have to like check in
with us you can check in but I guarantee
you that fing arm bar of grown man for
real he would love to he can arar a
grown man but a grown man can still take
him if they wanted to but he well he
actually says that he's like I can just
ride down to my front's house by myself
he's like I know what to do if somebody
kidnaps me he says like that's in his
mind because that's what I like
unfortunately you have to teach your
kids use your speed he knows yeah he
will speed that's why I'm I'm proud of
that like he [__] knows
he can run you stay right next to us at
all times don't use your speed you yell
and you stand right next to us cam is so
different like K's different he's he's
19 I'm like you want to uh run a mile
with me he's like sign me up for the
next marathon what are you talking about
I'm like you want to do some target
practice with the BB gun he's like I
could be in the FBI FBI want me right
now always
yeah I love it I like cam you want to
run the 5K when Daddy does the marathon
he's like how many miles is it I was
like three right three and a half
whatever that is he's like I guess can
we just do like the next one
up yeah for him it's not much no for me
I'm like I can barely [__] walk I'm
like I'm really put myself out there to
do this 5K you ready for what when I
realized I need to fix my B when I did
the 5K with Rosie are you ready for this
are you going to bring about doing that
yes I'm going to bring him up there was
a man you did so good so stor his hat
said
cancer zero me one I was like all right
cancer survivor good [__] old man old
white
man with a
walker a veteran in the 5K in the 5K and
the man was on my ass the whole
time cuz my back was locked the whole
time but he didn't pass you he didn't
pass was within 14 steps of my ass the
whole time there was a time I looked
back are you serious and I can't he was
not going fast it just my back was so
locked up I was just walking and my mom
was dusting me I went my mom is faster
than me oh and my back was completely
like my all the way down to my knees
[__] upu like you literally cannot was
to my knee to my hip to the middle you
fact that you even did that is is crazy
impressive with that bad back but this
man made me feel so stupid every time I
look back I was like it was like the dog
in Sandlot I was just waiting for him to
just he was so nice and he was so cool
but when he passed me when I did the
turnar around went you [__] what I'm
turning around your you're right there I
was like oh this is not it was just like
on a loop a loop so soon as I looped and
I came back past him he was not far
behind me that's okay and it motivated
you right yeah I had to go fix my back
to go but yeah so we're talking about
marathons that's what happened at mine
my back hurt walking from the marathon
to the finish line from my hotel to meet
her after she did her 26 mile marathon
and my back literally I can't believe
they do that like the fact that you guys
do that the full marathons and you just
are in it it's it's just so impressive
and amazing you're an athlete Thomas is
going to soccer phenomenon okay yes I
will I don't want to do that no I'm
saying we got to get so buff I'll do
that with you maybe if your back is I
love half
marathons our goal for this year is for
her to do like the some portion of those
something because I I've been trying to
like work really hard at my health and
like to get my [__] back in order even
though I'm still really
young all right yeah we
are we were 50 ago you were so young
when you were 38 I literally I'm almost
40 a lot of your fan base is like like
what early 20s like I like to think no
our biggest demographic is 28 to 35 oh I
love that that's great it's our biggest
demographic it's like 40% or something
like that I feel like for Our Generation
like we have a lot of younger fans 45 50
you're solid you're an adult now yes
right up through like you're a kid to
you're about 27 I love how you feel that
way cuz I feel like with our teenager
she makes me feel like I'm old as
[__] don't know
anything you know what I actually used
to be real [__] cool I know dumb new
[__] I'm going to be honest cuz you know
when you're young like yeah you think
this shit's dumb the stuff that we
thought that people thought we thought
was dumb it's classic and dope and
baller so we weren't wrong in our
generation the '90s was very sick so
much better like d and Nickelodeon was
not a fat that [__] was dope as
hell
my kids watch it all the so Rocko
generation has dog [__] it's all memes
goodg wasn't some corny ass movie it was
a sketch sound bad yeah what he's like
they downstairs watching gber I'm like
oh my God how cool he go it's new one
the
two I mean I'll watch it cam thought the
same got to watch the first one man
watchic got watch the first one you
can't watch come to America 2
first wait they haven't watched the
first one no our kids yes oh they have
okay that's why they wanted to watch the
second one and cam even said he watched
the second one he's like this isn't so
great the first one's better yes so he's
knows what he's talking about so don't
feel old cuz all the new [__] sucks yeah
exactly and all the stuff we said that
was cool and our parents like that
shit's dumb like yo no it's not actually
still popping I love your positivity
about that yeah when you're old is when
you're like yo I don't even want to get
up actually it's when you're online and
you [__] scroll to your birthday and
it takes like forever three [__]
Scrolls scroll
good that's Jes that happened to be
went scr you're still scrolling that's a
big
deal just be like one when you click
your age on how old are you this age is
this age oh that's terrible I just
went B of the 31 yes I just did that
with my personal trainer I was like
what's your age and what's your
demographic and it was like the cut off
was 37 37 to 45 now is that is that my
window that's your bracket that's my
[__] bracket with almost 50y olds
it's my thing now that's cool you're the
youngest one in the bracket yeah hell
yeah you're always going if you always
guess that's a good always join classes
with older people like yeah New
Blood you walk in feeling tight [__] a
generational
class of parents all day honestly one
day it's going to hit her how [__]
cool we are oh she all her friends got
old ass parents wait she doesn't think
you guys are cool I mean I think she
gets it but she's not like going to
openly admit going to say that she does
say sometimes that she appreciates it
and she's you know she's at an age where
she sees other people's households and
parents and how crazy her just resty
state of being is
like yeah you guys are all right right
guess you're fine okay no big deal
that's fine until she's older and then
realiz o I can't oh that's why kids
don't like me I treat them just like
they're 25 like hey shut
up oh no that that is me hey don't care
at all I do that I'll do that to my
brother in a heartbeat like start
complaining no one cares but you about
the complaining crying does nothing I'm
gonna Walk This Way yep I will do this I
did this how many times I do that smush
and walk off and they're like I hate
Thomas like no you don't there's a
healthy amount of that that's really
needed definitely oh hell yeah after
three or four times repeating myself or
like I will smos my own child get out of
here then if you think you're L if I
think I'm
lame cuz I told Rosie I feel bad cuz
it's like you're my kid that though but
you're a kid isn't that that's how Okay
as a teen okay but that's what I mean
I'm talking about as a teenager okay
your time when only when they think
they're tight no when they think they're
all cool like oh yeah I want to you my
friend that's so sad here not a little
kid he's pushing mushing toddlers in the
face that's what I got well yeah I'll
mush my little brother hell yeah's [__]
five must [__] I don't know I'm all
about the whole like tough [__] love
thing and I'm going to tell you how it
is but also at the same time coming from
like a a spot of like explaining and
understanding and like compassion for
your kid oh being like you're a [__]
[__] right you know no I'm I
explained everything and to the fullest
extent super nice no always first and
then night time I go hey stop our
nephew's only no the smoo is when
they're like it'd be better if I could
get this I go I don't know I just spent
$80 on your shoes that you said you
wanted but you think they're not cool no
more don't ask me for nothing y That's
what I'm talking about cuz one time I
agree one time say witch kid yeah let's
not say wi but he was talking [__] about
the shoes he wanted he's like I don't
like them like you picked them out I'm
buying them for you he's like these ones
are too tight I don't like them I want
those go but you just said you don't
like those and there's like 300 bucks
bro I'm buying a little child $300 shoes
of course not and then I went how about
this so these are two t I'll get you new
one like I don't like them I turned
around switched the shoes gave him the
same shoe back goes yeah the are so much
better and I broke it down like fool
you're not going to get that's the same
[__] shoe I just came he went oh yeah
don't try to lie to me but like little
kids like that but hey don't do that hey
by the way that's the same shoe uhhuh
I'm not mean to him like there's the
same shoe you lied to me yeah you go
like don't try to play me and I walk off
that's what I mean that's one of my
little brothers and sisters hated me oh
it's important to be able to explain
things on a rational level be like
actually this is what the [__] up oh
completely like yesterday when Johnny
like I shouldn't have to ask you eight
times just listen man come on don't spit
your rice on the table oh my God can you
not do that that's
gross simple I do it just like that like
they're like employee like don't do it
thank you employee I do like thank you
very much and I always say thank you
very
much in advance I leave it at that yeah
I feel like we did good with like
nipping that in the bud your kid are
dick kids no your kids are dicks cuz the
minute they were dicks we [__]
you're going throw a in a restaurant
taking the bathroom taking you the
bathroom and until you can [__] calm
yourself we're not leaving Oh I thought
you meant to go beat the [__] out of
taking the bathroom means beat the [__]
out of you my mom sorry that was a
threat that was a threat as a kider want
go to the
bathroom no I just if they wanted to
throw a [__] fight fit and cry in the
bathroom okay we're staying here until
you're done oh yeah for sure going the
really early on like I'm not [__]
around if you're going to [__] around in
a restaurant or act up or be
disrespectful the minute they know they
can get away with that is it's over over
oh yeah I'll leave the restaurant
completely pay for my food to go like
we're leaving now the car that's what my
mom did and I turned out good I'm like
you know what I got to instill don't be
a piece of [__] to me yeah you do and
honestly where we live in in Orange
County and like it's difficult cuz our
daughter goes to school with all these
wealthy pieces of [__] that haven't
worked for nothing in their life it's
like generational [__] and it's really
hard to hear that from our kids because
that's not how we grew up and I'm like
okay that that is how it is now like
this is my kids world that's cool so
it's like but at the same time like we
instill like you if you aren't doing
activities or anything at school get a
[__] job yeah if you're old enough
job some cool stuff do some cool [__]
jobs help work for us work for us work
for us I'm like you want to Shadow me
shadow your dad whatever but you have to
be doing something you're not doing
something I don't care 14 or 15 we're
not sticklers like I don't care what it
is you have to I think it's so important
like you should be doing something that
you're interested in so Marty's kids
will be selling oranges right on the
corner of their street very soon little
Emmy I just make sure you sell the
[__] will be they did have a little
stand at our old house they're sh the
oranges from the [__]
oranges we had three orange orange trees
and we did and we're like listen if you
guys want them go sell them completely
completely
kidding oh God that's cool I like that
oh my God you guys can I make a
reference to last episode we talked
about a little story I want to get your
perspective on I don't know if you
remember
this on Southside
Parkway when I thought we we possibly
witnessed a murder but we didn't do you
remember
that way me and your friend were sitting
on on the
porch and there were some horrible
screams across the street I don't I
don't know at what point you came out
but I really thought that we had
witnessed something horrible and a few
minutes went by till we realized we
didn't I think I do remember that but
then also we were like a second guessing
it cuz our right across immediate
Neighbors were like just we realized
that they were like drunks and like out
at all hours of the night I remember
that specifically all you yeah I don't
know if you were couldn't remember if
you were on the porch with us or not for
that but we talked about that last
episode and I also wanted to commend you
because we also went over that same
friend accidentally flashed extremely
explicit pictures at me
accidentally as your as your best
friend all right I know exactly and you
let her
live and she had to I had to go we both
went we all worked in the same place we
had to go back into work and finish our
shift and then I came home and was like
okay we all worked together we were all
really good friends this is my best
friend and she he came home he came home
first and was like listen he showed me
some inappropriate picture and told me
all how it went down and then I was like
wow I wonder when this [__] is that
like going to approach me is she really
embarrassed like what's going to happen
and immediately she T she's like I'm so
[__] sorry I'm so embarrassed and she
was just flipping through her pictures
showing him so cuz we were all friends
like I she was showing pictures of
Ariana and her son playing yes
Jesus and she she was flipping through
to find those pictures and it was her
vagina immediately she like
no she's like I'm so sorry I sent nudes
to my boyfriend and I was showing Marty
like before kids were playing my only F
my only fans mom mom feed that's a phone
of only fans mom like here's my children
naked here's some more
children I know it is friends with this
girl this is 20 years ago and every time
I see her and go back to New York
anytime I see she's like like a couple
times a year we're like remember when
you showed Marty this picture we just
laugh so hard but I was you handled that
like a g yeah I did cuz I don't give a
[__] like if I knew if she was doing
that intentionally like obviously she'd
it'd be a [__] problem because she
wasn't and like it was just a funny
[__]
thing funny so much more horrible Marty
feels horrible about it it was the worst
I remember what I was going to ask right
what is your you know the story what is
your perspective on the worst road trip
ever without saying names or
anything the worst road trip ever when
we went yes towards Northern and we
picked up that yes
wow is this dictionary what oh we picked
up the hooker not us no not us not us
sorry the person that we were with yeah
full tell the story so
it sounded like an awesome road trip it
was supposed to be a great road trip it
was very interesting as we started
writing with this person who of course
is what 12 hours late
yes wait before we even left
yes so he's 12 hours late drove to Santa
Cruz RoR set too to meet him closer oh
my God 12 hours late and you had it did
you have to expense a whole extra night
somewhere my sister lived there yeah his
sister lived there so we were okay so
then we take off everything seems fun F
it's
cool I fell asleep most the away mhm I
just remember it was really beautiful
and then all of a sudden like we pull
over and like we're pulling over and
he's talking about picking somebody
up and this girl gets in the car and
like not to say she's not an average
girl but just you know something's up
you hopped in the back with me or did
she sit in the back with me she sat in
the front I a sit next to that b okay I
was going to say I can't remember where
she sat for a second and then I just and
then it just clicked sorry as we're
driving he makes it so like not hostile
but just like damn why are you saying
things like that to her he's playing
music or he's saying something to her
saying like oh you wish you got okay
like you wish you got to like her you
don't got to like that or something like
that and he's like pointing to me and
Thomas and I'm like what the [__] is
going
on we woke up to this in the back seat
you wish you got it like her like what
like I had someone that liked you cuz he
didn't like her she saying that to the
girl referring to us okay all right cuz
we're like all next to each other and
you wish you were like that somebody if
you pass out in the back with Marty
you're going to lay on Marty that's
probably how it was yeah all right and
it was just so like I didn't really
understand what was going on cuz I was
just trying to be like it's just this
friend it's whatever and then I'm like
no but we also know this person we know
our friend is a pimp yeah like an actual
pimp this person that's like that we
know that guy okay our driver he's our
driver we GNA call him I know we don't
want to beat into the ground that fo
gets all butt hurt I don't want to talk
about too much about him it's an old
Dead story but it's a funny story he
pimps women anyway continue he's
breaking this [__] down in the front
seat literally breaking her down like
you wish you had it like that you wish
you had like pretty much like my life
and it was like what the hell's going oh
that's like level one mental Warfare of
where you start with yes you start
breaking them down first we' never seen
this before ever that's horrible it was
your expense no he said that like once
it felt so intense the whole time like
and I don't [__] with you song kept
playing he played that and he kept
saying it to her it to her pointing at
her like like that what was she doing
just sitting there sitting there like
this that was it that's sad yeah it was
really sad that's not the end of the
story though we done we have a whole
road trip with this we picked her up
like what half this is a road trip oh my
God we're on a 800 mile road trip durble
Road Trip the that this continues into a
fullblown we still got to stay the night
for a few days up in or and then we come
back home still no our friend's 12 hours
late we fall asleep as we're going to
Portland we're almost to Portland and
he's like hey I'm going to pick up my
friend go huh
who comes back 30 minutes later with
some girl in a bag she's booty shorts
I'm like oh God please don't tell me
it's a hooker dude please tell me it's
just a girl you're talking to I feel
like OG now telling my story you tell it
so much better I you tell it so much
better like wait how did we get to this
point get in the car and we're just
hanging out for like an hour I falely I
wake up and he's just belittling this
woman look at that you ain't never going
to have nobody like that no nobody's
going to love you like that oh my God
wish you had it like that wish that song
came out he started doing this you like
in her face as he's driving and she's
just sitting there like this I'm pretty
sure she was like on her phone or
something but she was just sitting there
it was the most awkward
experience and then we finally Drive the
what next 12 hours with her as well and
that goes on the whole entire time it
was so weird award that's gross it was
so weird she was just taking it yeah it
was so I mean it wasn't constant no but
it was very down it was no she couldn't
care less no she didn't care she was
looking at the
full this's a loser that's how she like
I need my ride just exactly what that's
what the vibe she was giving off
like say literally [__] idiot I do
this
exactly that's exactly the vibe cuz in
the end I cuz I know he's me and him get
into it he was one of my really good
friends he was I loved that I thought
he'd be at our wedding I thought i''d be
friends with him yeah you have that such
cuz you know what I know what he does
but you know when you meet somebody that
does horrible things like You're a good
ass person like why do you do this I
have a couple friends that are like that
you're a good he is a good person you do
something directly to me to like
jeopardized me or my family it's easy to
be like hey you're probably not making
the best decisions but I still love you
like I have that's exactly I have faith
yes I always have like dreams where I
talk to I'm still homies with them I
want to help you it does bug me cuz was
one of the funest people I ever met in
my life of
course if it doesn't bother you you're
not a human right but you you can't have
that but you still have that empathy for
people friends with the history that
it's like I want to help you I want you
to get your [__] together I want like
you can't just cut people I have friends
like that yeah it's hard and until you
really like impact my life directly I'm
always going to try to have love for you
and help you a friend that fell into
drugs again recent ly and I love her to
death and we have a 20 year history and
I I wanted to like offer my home to her
to help her but at the same time I have
kidses little kids you're not going to
take it and you're you're just I I can't
have it in my life same it we have the
same situations I have two H half
Brothers one that's doing really great
and another one that's not that's in
jail and reached out to me just because
we're brother and sister like I I can't
have that in my life if I'm trying to
you built all this already it yeah it'
be like it's be crazy like yo it's
apocalypse let's let this zombie in
here you know what he's going to do to
this house I know I know we just secured
the house yeah we just secured the house
let's just open up let's just let this
one in true that's so true because drugs
are different once you're in drugs
you're not the same person that's so
true that's why he's in I have the
brother that's in jail right now solely
because of
drugs s we do anything for drug we tell
sad did I ever tell you what happened no
went because he got on drugs his mom was
always on drugs kind drug his mom I I
think first started like cocaine and
then it was meth
yeah and the mom was 19 when she had him
my dad was like 37 so she was 18 when
she got pregnant oh your dad was the man
when he was younger yeah that's why just
my brother but the mom was so much
younger but she was like a drug addict
so when he was born you know she got
into some [__] and then he got his life
together always lived with the
grandparents but then went back and
lived with mom got all [__] up into
drugs and he connected with us a couple
times yeah I I was trying cuz I was like
hey you're my brother you know like I
want to try to help you I want to like
everything that you're going through
gone through like doesn't Define you
like I'm trying to you know guide him
through this then all of a sudden he's
in the news him and his mom tried to rob
a drug dealer he had a gun with him and
ended up shooting the guy so he got
attempted murder oh she didn't die no
the guy didn't die I think I I don't
even know I want to say think obviously
guy than God but like for like what do
you expect when you do something like
that that's why drugs are such a
terrible thing because you
just Jesus yeah so what is he like 20
he's damn as hell way no by now when I
first started reconnecting with him he
was about that age but right now I
thought he was way younger than that I
thought he was like a kid like a
teenager barely younger than 19 19 20 27
is not that long he had his mom who was
hooked on drugs this poor kid as I say
like lately poor kid cuz his
circumstances always [__]
him but at the same time like nobody's
going to give a [__] about you but you
you know you have
to move beyond your circumstances and
that was really tough for me cuz he's my
brother brother like I wanted to help
him out but also at the same time we're
so far removed from that how what's it
going to look for like for me for my
attempted murder brother to get out of
jail and I'm like hey come stay with
me with my kids in the house hell no
hell no yeah ship a sale basically for
anybody
anybody my even like my sisters are
amazing like we've we've tried to help
them out every way we can but it's like
if you don't have the ambition
at at a certain point in your life you
have to take responsibility for your own
[__] traumas no traumas like nobody's
going to give a [__] about you but you
so join the Army oh my God join the Army
join the Army that's what I
heard k
no join the military if your M's got you
pulling uh yeah go join the military if
your mom likes to do drugs with you
that is a better option back to the hook
God back to the hooker story so I
basically I would have never remembered
out to that
girl the message is to her nothing
defines you you are who you are you can
get past this hooker you can always do
better right your message applies to the
hooker if she's out there watching oh my
God how did I even get you know what
she's doing she just stopped at Denny's
as a waitress looked up with a screen
saw that I remember when she saw Forest
running I remember that we always bring
and we always bring it back always comes
back to Forest com so the hooker
watching just heard your
story guy says as the trunks's open you
got to help me ditch this [__] it's
back to the
story and then she just ditches him and
I think he was like I got to ride cuz he
didn't want to be embarrassed like she
left me I think I don't know
anyway so then the event happened the
event was cool it was dope and then are
we talking about the way back or are we
going into full detail of the event no
no that's fine uh we did mushrooms they
didn't do anything they didn't and then
we got stuck on this weird guy playing
instruments and then we had to like
break he was weird he was do some spell
it felt like we were almost in a trance
so we had to walk away but it was really
interesting it was weird I like him he
had puppets it was weird they were
wooden puppets it was weird we thought
the mushrooms didn't work and then we we
saw Panda there it was oh yeah the panda
story where the guy came out of the
woods same night got yeah same night oh
okay that's oh my God that's a
Pand much more sense now we saw the
panda first then got stuck on almost
stuck in that trance yes then we broke
that yeah and then we hung out in the
bus plot yeah we hung out in the bus
spot and our friend had ate a bunch of
Edibles and just slept in the car the
the Fred that we came with literally
just he didn't handle Edibles well and
then we tried to wake him up cuz he ride
and he didn't wake up for 20 minutes
we're I'm punching the window and he's
asleep at the steering wheel takes 20
minutes to wake him up he won't let us
drive we're trying to tell him like the
mushrooms didn't work we're fine he was
like nah you guys aren't going to drive
you guys are on mushrooms no no no and
then he drove us back like this that's
all I remember like that going 8 miles
an hour my God and he's laughing at us n
you guys are on mus so bro we're like no
we're totally fine fine I even told him
I could drive skip the whole piece wait
what piece did I miss piece right when I
get to the window I noticed throw up all
over the window this full PUK oh my God
no wait in his boots on his boots in his
boots in his boots in his Bo and then as
we're driving he rolls the window down
and throws up again we already didn't
want to go and then he was 12 hours
sleep and then he picked up that girl
and made it all awkward no it gets so
much worse like I don't want him to get
upset and stuff but we got into a
situation where he lost all the money
that we had right cuz there was a casino
there right I can't I'm I'm not done we
wake up we got to get a a hotel we stay
an extra
day he's T and he's like I'm going to
stay a few days I'm like I'm not staying
a few days by Canada because you want me
to drive back now or get me a a plane
ticket right now not staying not
happening so
this is why I say he's a good
person cuz he tried he did try he did
try oh it gets worst the worst part
different the worst part is coming April
the worst part so we somehow get a hotel
even though he lost all his
money and then he gets us a
flight we're getting our [__] ready
we're going to the airport did I miss
anything no heading to the airport as
we're pulling up pulling up to par to
the terminal like it's literally in my
eyesight he looks at both of us and he
says someone goes to your seat he gives
us tickets he says if someone goes to
your seat and says you're in my seat
just get up and leave leave the plane
leave the plane leave the plane call me
and then I'll get you another
flight so he had standby seats he had
somebody hack somebody hack in Airline
and putting our names registered as we
paid but if someone bought it then we
just got to get up we got to get up
before we get caught for fraud and it's
the time we had no money I had no way to
get home that's why I want to go Choice
well that's how those people um do the
drugs from different countries and lost
and stuck yeah they're like I was scared
called somebody to scared yeah but
flying back home was so scary the whole
time until I got my bag got in the car
literally cuz I was nervous cuz we had
to check bags we had suitcases with us
M dude f up so yeah his homie hacked
into it what if they kept my bag and
then they're like no you got to come
pick up your bag over here and then be
like yo how did you ha how did you get
into our system to book yourself a
ticket all of that stuff was going
through my head the whole entire time
you accepted as we pulled up to the
terminal he goes by the way no he was
like I swear to God he goes I got you
guys flights let's go I can take you
guys don't worry about it like okay dope
he got us tickets literally as we're
about to get out of the car by the way 8
seconds as we're about to slow down and
park and he's going to let us out he
goes by the way if anybody sits in your
seat and says your seat you get up and
you call I go what do you mean he goes
you don't really have tickets I
go just get on just go just go just go
I'm going to lose but if it happens just
no but he didn't tell me the hacking
thing until we landed I know but that's
what drug dealers do they don't tell you
until you are tell me
until he's a okay cuz not even that he
goes if somebody gets up just get off
call me and what do you mean you know
what super normal let me just get on I
don't care and I just thought like if
somebody sits in the seat we're going to
get in trouble what did he do I was just
thinking the second we go througha we're
going to get fled yeah I was like did he
steal the tickets you there's no way
they would have listened to your story
they would been like I am crazy you're
going to jail you're going to jail [__]
shouldn't have done it shouldn't should
have realized that's why it's so crazy
worse than having drugs on a plane like
a million times you hacked a federal
sister to steal and commit fraud to
transport across state lines two people
and you can't play like you don't know
no I didn't know till we landed but they
will not give a [__] yeah I I know we
landed know we've been here for two and
a half hours really yes we wow two and a
half feel like it flew by it really did
maybe like two cuz you have to cut out
like 35
minutes nothing's cut out it has to be
edited in one day we're actually
uploading it completely yeah
I yeah I'm not even looking at this for
what he goes
through when you say the names she wants
bleeped out just emphasize them loud and
make them pop up on the screen yeah put
I'll put her picture in her IG handle oh
there you go there you go it's really
rude that's really
rude are you drunk oh I'm
both both I didn't say anything else
what I'm saying I got you are you hungry
I'm both both two
combined oh my gosh ail I love you I
love you oh all right so fourth kid on
the way is that what you're saying these
condition what does that mean Mar do you
have to have another child is
that can we get like a a replay on that
face real
quick yo
I've known you for a minute now like
that was a genuine drop your face your
face looked genuinely like what the hell
are you wow you really idea this
whole she's she's serious I'm like
you're not [__] serious right you
know what you should do it's this hard
you should do a vlog you should do a
vlog and then show her what is posted
like God have insect me without my
wife's approval honestly I wouldn't even
care I wouldn't even be upset I've been
telling on I said I think it's unfair
that I've been in birth control my whole
life and you should get ectomy so I'm
I'm down with it fairness that's what
snip snip listen we're we'll talk about
the
lasac baby steps and babies you had no
baby steps that's what I'm trying to
that was a horrible way to say it we'll
take baby steps around these babies so
they don't have baby
steps oh my God Jesus Christ he's a
rapper he's a raer so follow Marty's
Myspace all right if you want if you're
trying to get
seduced any other women out there trying
to get seduced you follow this Myspace
what's the my space sto
hick wow wow that's good some word
play what what I missed it why so hick I
put emphasis on hick oh cuz you oh cuz
you're a hick cuz I'm he's born in the
city you're the one in the country you
just said it yeah you rode in the back
of a truck you run back of truck in the
cut that's fine yeah that's what her
tattoo I guess you're right she's got
the stoic tattoo I do have the stoic
hick hick all right we've been here for
a long time we told a bunch of dumb
stuff we got through about two of 30
notes I had so we gra there's a lot more
there's there is a lot we can do another
episode yeah we can do
something yeah that straight moonshine
and she's trying to say she's not a hit
she's like I made
I made this
Stoick
moonshine but I'm a city girl actually a
soccer
player what hick do you don't play
soccer what none none exactly oh my God
okay no no Rosy is more of a hick than
any single one of you so pretty funny I
outrank it's pretty funny I think I
outrank all you love it um all right
she's a boss
[__] I love where this is
going what she grew up on an actual Farm
that's your muscle Rosie I don't have
muscles please yes you do you [__]
R's
gotes she hate the bells
oh I'm just kidding bail the
hey why do that [__] sound
off hey man that one little piece of Joy
was
good hey is the first time I ever seen
you smoke ever mhm I was smoking at the
party on the [__] Sprinter van no you
yes I was oh she did hit it you hit it I
didn't know
that not the same amount of
time all right cool shout out to puppy
for being nice when Ros R grappling no
grappling don't be a Grappler all
right this has been another episode of
the do's usual podcast there's been a
lot a little bit of wine some drink some
mango juice cuz I am
thirsty guys oh [__] sorry I was about
to chug it like we're done I'm sorry I'm
burnt we drove far we drove from her
said right now we did I'm tired sorry
thank you guys so much for being here uh
from Martin Lawrence the the lady that
taught the Ninja Turtles how not to Die
April O'Neal Rosie rice and me that's my
nickname me thank you guys so much for
being here I appreciate it um yeah I'm
[__] hi have a dope ass day thanks
guys for watching appreciate it thank
you for Marie O'Neal April O'Neal Rosie
rice you guys and I have a dope ass day
hey guys hey hey hey we should all have
a [__] shot right now oh I was like
what is that I know what you just
[Music]
did
perfect
[Music]